Menschen helfen das ist eine
Binsenweisheit aber es ist keine
Entschuldigung den Menschen zu helfen
den man helfen kann und das ist der
Auftrag den sich diese Koalition
gestellt hat regelbasiert konsequent
aber auch menschlich diesen Weg gehen
wir und dafür kann ich der
Bundesregierung die volle Unterstützung
der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion zusagen
[Applaus]
Matthias Helfrich wird der nächste
Redner sein fraktionslos früher mal AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es war ja
bisher bekannt dass die Amnesie im
Bundeskanzleramt kassiert neu ist aber
dass die Amnesie pandemisch geworden ist
und nunmehr auch die scheinen
Oppositionelle cdu/csu-fraktion
ergriffen hat es waren doch sie liebe
Christdemokraten die sich 2015 mit einem
willkommens-putsch an unserer Heimat
versündigt haben es waren doch sie die
Deutschland in einem Akt des
souveränitätsverzichts der
Massenzuwanderung ausgeliefert haben er
kann mich gerne nachhäfen und das
belächeln es war nämlich auch sie die
die ich will gucken nach Fries nach
Deutschland eingeladen haben die dann
nachher auf der Kölner Domplatte unsere
Frauen belästigten beklauten und
begraften schon vergessen das waren sie
von der CDU aber unter guten
Christenmenschen ist es ja üblich zu
vergeben und an die Leute rum des
Sünders zu glauben Manfred Weber ging
hier ja bereits als Gläubiger und
geläuterter Paulus voran und gratulierte
weil Siegerin Georgia Meloni in Teilen
ist ihre Analyse richtig aber sie leidet
unter einem falschen wertehorizont die
Zielgrößen ihres Maßnahmenkataloges sind
die falschen es geht bei der Bekämpfung
der illegalen Migration nicht um die
Akzeptanz eines dysfunktionalen
Asylsystems und einer gescheiterten
Einwanderungsgesellschaft nein es muss
bei der Bekämpfung der
illegalen Migration um den Erhalt
Deutschlands als Land der deutschen
gehen und eine Forderung gefällt mir
ganz besonders gut von ihm unter Ziffer
7 fordern sie ja die Einführung eines
sogenannten
rückführungsbeauftragten wenn sich die
Ampel einig ist die er eine
rückführungsoffensive wünscht und sie
ein rückführungsbeauftragten Wünschen
der dann würde ich mich als
überparteilicher
chemikationsbeauftragte anbieten und ich
verspreche Ihnen abzuschieben wie noch
nie in diesem Land abgeschoben werden
wurde und sollten wir uns nicht auf mich
einigen können dann geht weiterhin Jörg
Haiders Alter Grundsatz bevor die polit
das Volk austauschen sollte das Volk die
Politiker austauschen und das gilt für
die Unionspolitiker genauso wie für die
ampelpolitiker vielen Dank
Matthias Helferich fraktionslos und ich
habe vorhin gesagt früher afd-mitglied
in der AFD ist ja immer noch aber er
gehört der Fraktion nicht mehr
vor so und dann wird er möglicherweise
noch einen Ordnungsruf bekommen von
einer ösus der Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
für einen Ausdruck den er in seiner Rede
verwendet hat nächster Redner Marcel
Emmerich Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ob man im Innenausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
wenn man sich diese Debatte jetzt mal
wieder angehört hat wir sind ja schon am
Ende der Debatte fast dann muss man sich
einfach ja kann man einfach feststellen
auch wenn man sich ihren Antrag noch mal
durchliest dass das was die Union hier
verbreitet und mir im Antrag
aufgeschrieben hat er ein
migrationspolitischer Irrweg ist und
nicht unsere Politik ein
migrationspolitischer politischer
Sonderweg das kann man mal zweifellos
feststellen an dieser Stelle und sie
haben uns den Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der koalitionsfraktion
vorgeworfen dass wir keinen Kontakt
hätten zu den Kommunen zu den
Landrätinnen und Landräten ich glaube
dass mitnichten der Fall das haben wir
alle und die bundesinnenministerin hat
mit den über 50
bundesimmobilien die sie da zur
Entlastung
bereitstellt auch gezeigt dass sie den
Druck wahrnimmt und das da etwas
passiert das heißt wir sind da
handlungsfähig und helfen den Kommunen
und den Ländern
und wenn man sich hier einen Antrag
anschaut dann muss man ja schon mal
feststellen dass das ist keine
Überraschungen aber wo ist denn
eigentlich ihr sozialer Flügel wo ist
denn eigentlich ihr christlich
orientierter Flügel sie sind vollkommen
weg wenn man ihre reden hört dann stellt
man fest dass es ihnen in Wahrheit darum
geht und dass die richtig juckt mal
wieder das Wort Obergrenzen in den Mund
zu nehmen ihr Parteivorsitzender März
hat ja auch das schon alles mit den
narrativen vorbereitet mit dem
sozialtourismus und der
Entsolidarisierung mit den geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine und jetzt gehen sie her
und bekämpfen die geflüchteten die über
die Balkanroute kommen in dem ersten
Schritt um dann in einem späteren
zweiten Schritt zu sagen wir brauchen
eine Obergrenze das ist die Debatte die
Sie gerade vorbereiten und das ist ein
vollkommener migrationspolitischer
Irrweg den wir nicht mitgehen
und wo ist denn ihr Wirtschaftsflügel
der ist auch überhaupt nicht da wenn man
im Wahlkreis unterwegs ist das könnten
Sie übrigens mal machen bei
Handwerksbetrieben dann stellt man fest
dass es überall fehlt egal ob sie in der
Bäckerei ist oder wenn man unterwegs ist
in dem Altenheim da viel Pflegepersonal
überall fehlt Personal überall fehlen
Leute egal ob es einfach Arbeitskräfte
oder Fachkräfte sind und das was sie
hier vorschlagen ist Abschottung und
Ausgrenzung und hat überhaupt nichts mit
einer vernünftigen mit einer geregelten
asyl- und Migrationspolitik zu tun
sondern ist einfach nur Schranken
hochziehen und keine Menschen mehr
reinlassen sie wollen ein großes
Stoppschild errichten so wie sie das
auch in den letzten Jahren mit den
Grenzkontrollen gemacht haben wie sie
das mit der Forderung nach dem Gedicht
unserer Sicherheit stattdessen gibt es
viele andere bessere Alternativen die
wir da an den auf den Weg bringen können
und das machen wir auch als Koalition
das ist uns auch als grüner Fraktion ein
sehr sehr wichtiges Anliegen wir
betreiben ihr Spiel
auf keinen Fall mit wir werden uns
dagegen auflehnen sie können hier
fordern und sprechen wie Sie wollen aber
ihre Politik die wird bei uns keinen
Einhalt geboten bekommen
Marcel Emmerich und das geht mir die
Gelegenheiten noch eine kleine Korrektur
anzubringen zu der Anmerkung von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Aidan ölsu ist
eben aber zogen auf die Rede von
Matthias Helferich es ging nicht um
einen Ausdruck sondern es ging darum was
er hoch gehalten hat das wollte sie sich
noch mal angucken
sicherheitshalber und dann sich hat sich
dann vorbehalten einen Ordnungsruf unter
Umständen nachträglich zu erteilen wenn
sie es dann gesehen hat Josip youratovic
ist am Pult ist der letzte Redner in
dieser Debatte und er kommt aus der
spd-fraktionspolitik und
asylrechtsfragen vermischt werden
Migrationspolitik ist mehr
als nur Asylrecht bei Migrationspolitik
geht es in erster Linie um Integration
in unserer Gesellschaft und in den
Arbeitsmarkt deswegen werden wir wie im
Koalitionsvertrag gefordert Deutschland
zu einem modernen Einwanderungsland
machen dies befördert die reguläre
Migration die automatisch die irreguläre
reduziert den Fakt ist angesichts der
fehlenden 400.000 Beschäftigten in
Deutschland brauchen wir die Migration
die es in die europäische Raum nicht
mehr so gibt deshalb begrüße ich
ausdrücklich die Maßnahme der
Bundesregierung wie zum Beispiel das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht dies bietet
auch den jungen Menschen die zu uns
Pflichten sich hier zu integrieren und
sich zu unsere freiheitlichen
demokratischen Grundordnung bekennen
sowie sich beruflich einbringen die
Möglichkeit hier bleiben zu können statt
in der Ungewissheit der Duldungen zu
verharren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und gerade Herr
throm sie wissen selbst die Diskussionen
die man täglich fährt in unseren
Wahlkreis nämlich dass die gerade die
Unternehmer und Ausbilder nicht die Welt
verstehen dass die junge Migranten
integrieren und ausbilden und sie dann
abzuschieben
während wir hier tenderinnen nach
Fachkräften gesucht suchen mit anderen
Worten der die reguläre Migration
stärken und die irreguläre Migration
reduzieren will dem helfen keine
zusätzliche Schranken vielmehr müssen
wir als DemokratInnen einen rechtlichen
Rahmen auf den Grundlage von mehr
Menschlichkeit statt Rainer Bürokratie
schaffen dies verlangen von uns
Millionen von MitbürgerInnen die mit
ihren unermüdlichen Einsatz helfen das
menschliche Gesicht unserer Gesellschaft
zu wahren statt hier wie von
verschiedenen Kollegen der CDU
halbherzige Lob zu bekunden und wenn es
schon um eine Veränderung oder eine
Veränderung geben soll muss man sich im
europäischen Rahmen Gedanken machen wie
wir die Best West bestehende
Konventionen anpassen indem wir die
Fluchtursachen neu definieren neu
definieren und anerkennen zum Beispiel
dass man den Krieg auch Umwelt nach dem
dass man neben dem Krieg auch
Umweltschäden und Hungersnot als
Fluchtursachen berücksichtig
t dabei muss man sich Gedanken machen
die wir angesichts weltweit 90 Millionen
Flüchtlingen Fluchtursachen bekämpfen
statt neue bürokratische Hürde oder gar
Zäune an der Grenzen aufstellen so zum
Beispiel ist meines Erachtens nach
wichtig dass wir in unserer Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik in den
Herkunftsländer neben den
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit auch den
Sozialstaat konditionell als wichtigen
Bestandteil der Demokratie exportieren
und zum Schluss kann ich mir nicht
verkneifen als gläubiger Christ in das
sozialdemokratischen Partei gerade sie
von der Union als christliche Partei
sollten eins Wissen der Jesus Christus
war der prominenteste Flüchtling und
alles was sie tun in ihrer Politik
gegenüber den Flüchtlingen tun sie den
den Jesus Christus an danke danke für
Ihre aufmerkung
mit einem christlichen Zitat er ist ja
auch Vorsitzender der
deutsch-südosteuropäischen
Parlamentariergruppe und in diesem und
Kontext war ja auch die Grenzen Serbiens
immer mal wieder ein Thema in dieser
Debatte der Antrag der Unionsfraktion
wird überwiesen in den Innenausschuss
und da noch mal diskutiert hier geht's
weiter mit zwei Gesetzentwürfen gleich
zum einen zum sogenannten
wohngeldplus-gesetz und zum anderen um
ein
heizkostenzuschussgesetz das Wohngeld
plus Gesetz wird eingebracht von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP kurz der ampelfraktion und das
heizkostenzuschussgesetz wird hier
eingebracht von der Bundesregierung
beide Gesetzgebungsverfahren beide die
beide Inhalte der jeweiligen Gesetze
hängen natürlich zusammen mit der
Energiekrise mit der energiekostenkrise
das Wohngeld plus war schon angekündigt
worden im Jul Form der Bundesregierung
es ist Teil des entlastungspaketes 3
eben so wie dann weiteren Verlauf der
Debatten auch noch mal über weitere
Heizkostenzuschüsse beispielsweise das
können wir heute Nachmittag dann
übrigens auch noch mal
auf der Tagesordnung wenn es um eine
energiepreispauschale an
rentner-rentnerinnen und
versorgungsbeziehende geht diese Debatte
sollte eigentlich beginnen
mit der
Bundesinnenminister mit der
bundesbahnministerin oder sehen wir sie
auch klarer gaiwitz auf dem Weg zum Pult
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete die
hohen Energiepreise treffen viele
Menschen in Deutschland hart aber am
härtesten treffen sie doch diejenigen
die sowieso mit sehr wenig Geld
auskommen müssen und sie spüren das ganz
direkt in Ihrem eigentlich
geschütztesten Lebensumfeld nämlich der
Wohnung die Wohnung kostet bereits jetzt
einen großen Teil ihres Einkommens und
angesichts der stark gestiegenen Reise
bleibt am Ende nur noch sehr wenig zum
Leben sehr wenig auch zum Konsumieren
deshalb setzt das dritte
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung
genau hier an bei den Wohnkosten von
Menschen mit niedrigen Einkommen und
zwar zielgerichtet um keine Zeit zu
verlieren haben wir die beiden
Gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt die heute in
erster Lesung beraten werden und gerade
um bevorstehenden Winter schnell und
unbürokratisch helfen zu können sehen
wir vor wohngeldempfängern mit einem
zweiten Heizkostenzuschuss zu
unterstützen
dieser soll im Vergleich zum ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss deutlich erhöht
werden für einen Einpersonenhaushalt von
270 auf immerhin 415 Euro für ein zwei
Personen-Haushalt von 350 auf ganze 540
Euro und für jede weitere Person im
Haushalt 100 Euro zusätzlich
[Applaus]
wichtig ist dass auch erneut beziehen
nur von Leistungen nach dem BAföG und
Ausbildungs- und
berufsausbildungsbeihilfen von dieser
Hilfe profitieren und die halten 200
statt 230 nun 345 Euro die Wohnkosten
sind jedoch so stark gestiegen dass
künftig noch mehr Menschen unsere
Unterstützung brauchen deshalb sehen wir
eine große Reform des wohngeltes vor und
sie soll zum ersten ersten 2023 in Kraft
treten mit dem Wohngeld plus sehen wir
vor den Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
von bisher 600.000 Haushalte auf rund
zwei Millionen Haushalte mit immerhin
4,5 Millionen Menschen zu erhöhen
zugleich erhöhen wir die Zahlung
durchschnittlich von rund 180 auf rund
370 Euro pro Monat eine riesensteigerung
das heißt also mit dem Wohngeld plus
wird der Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
verdreifacht und durch die doppelte
durch die durchschnittliche Monatsrate
verdoppelt außerdem integrieren wir in
das Wohngeld künftig eine dauerhafte
heizkostenkomponente hierbei wird nicht
die Heizungsrechnung direkt bezahlt
sondern eine pauschale und auch das ist
ein wichtiger Anreiz zum Energiesparen
darüber hinaus führen wir einen Zuschlag
ein der berücksichtigt dass viele
Wohnungen in Kürze energetisch saniert
werden müssen und dadurch die Mieten
steigen werden das ist ein wichtiger
Beitrag für eine sozialgerechte
Klimawende
nicht zuletzt wird das Wohngeld auch
unbürokratischer und passgenauer wir
verlängern die möglichen
Bewilligungszeitraum von 12 auf 18
Monate und wir ermöglichen es den
Ländern einfache schneller Auszahlung
des Wohngeldes vorzunehmen und wenn die
Mieter erhöht wird kann das Wohngeld in
Zukunft schon jetzt schon angepasst
werden wenn sie um 10 und nicht erst wie
jetzt um 15 Prozent steigt das Wohngeld
ist und bleibt eine der zielgenauesten
staatlichen Unterstützungsleistungen
überhaupt denn es berücksichtigt
gleichzeitig Einkommen Haushaltsgröße
und Wohnkosten übrigens und das wissen
viele nicht deswegen werbe ich dafür
auch um selbstgenutzten Eigenheim
es erreicht somit exakt diejenigen die
es am drinksten brauchen darunter viele
Alleinerziehende Menschen und das ist
mir auch wichtig Rentnerinnen und
Rentner sind fast die Hälfte der
wohngeldbeziehenden Haushalte und
Familien mit geringen Einkommen so wie
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner von alten und
Pflegeheimen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren der Gesetzentwurf für das
Wohngeld Plus ist die größte
wohngeldreform in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik er wurde innerhalb
kürzester Zeit auf den Weg gebracht und
ich weiß dieses für alle Beteiligten
auch für Sie natürlich ein großer
Kraftakt ich danke den Ländern für ihre
Unterstützung und für den intensiven
Austausch in den letzten Wochen genau zu
der Frage wie wir das möglichst
unbürokratisch organisieren und ich
danke den Kommunen vor allen Dingen den
Mitarbeitenden der wohngeldstellen die
sich jetzt schon vorbereiten auf die
vielen neuen Anträge und auch wenn wir
uns zügig an die Umsetzung machen werden
werden die Auszahlungen einige Zeit in
Anspruch nehmen wo wir als
baumministerium mit Vereinfachungen
helfen können tun wir das gerne und wenn
wir die Länder unterstützen können das
Wohngeld digital auszuzahlen wie es
schon viele Bundesländer auch tun helfen
wir auch sehr gerne ich bitte Sie nun
ich bitte Sie nun um konstruktive
parlamentarische Beratung damit wir die
Betroffenen mit dem Wohngeld Plus und
dem Heizkostenzuschuss schnell und
verlässlich unterstützen können
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
Bundesministerin für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen mit ihren
Ausführungen zum Wohngeld plus Gesetzes
soll erhöht werden das Wohngeld und es
soll deutlich mehr Bezieher und
BezieherInnen geben in Zukunft wenn
dieses Gesetz in Kraft tritt Jan Marko
Luczak aus der Unionsfraktion ist der
erste gegenredner Sprecher für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
wir haben seit dem Beginn diesen
furchtbaren angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und der energiepreiskrise etwas
was fast schon so ein bisschen ein
Schema der Ampel ist wir haben die
Situation dass wir als Union Vorschläge
machen für notwendige Maßnahmen wir
sehen aber dass die Ampel dann zögert
dass die zaudert dass sie mal grün
blinkt mal gelb meistens steht sie aber
auf rot und irgendwann nach viel Streit
auch in der Koalition bewegt sich die
Ampel dann doch aber es ist dann zu spät
halbherzig und meistens ist es dann auch
noch mit handwerklichen Mängeln versehen
das war beim Leistungspaket so beim
ersten das war beim ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss so das war und ist ja
immer noch bei der Frage der
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke so so war es bei der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Energieträger so ist es bei der
gasumlage die moox war so ist es beim
gaspreisdeckel wo wir immer noch nicht
genau wissen wie genau der ausgestaltet
ist wo jetzt nur klar ist das wird
irgendwann frühestens im März in Kraft
treten also nach dem Winter wo da finde
ich hat meine Kollegin Julia Klöckner
das gestern sehr gut gesagt das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn man jemanden nach
dem Winter sagt ich habe hier ein paar
tolle Winterreifen für dich möchtest du
nicht kaufen das ist viel zu spät die
Menschen brauchen jetzt Klarheit sie
brauchen jetzt eine Entlastung und da
kommen sie nicht hinterher liebe
Kollegin von der Ampel
und genauso ist es auch bei der Reform
des wohngelds im März im März diesen
Jahres haben wir als Union in einem
Entschließungsantrag bereits gefordert
dass wir einen höheren Zuschuss bei den
Heizkosten brauchen dass wir die
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas senken müssen dass
wir eine Ausweitung des Kreises der
wohngeldberechtigung benötigen und dass
wir das Wohngeld koppeln müssen an die
Energiekosten
jetzt
Mitte Oktober 7 Monate später jetzt
ziehen sie als Ampel endlich nach das
ist viel zu spät sie haben über Monate
die Unsicherheit und die sorgen dann
Nöte der Menschen nicht ernst genommen
die warme Wohnung meine Damen und Herren
das darf doch nicht zu schuldenfälle
werden genauso wie ein Heizlüfter kein
Statussymbol sein darf und deswegen
müssen sie schneller sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
und jetzt will ich der einen Satz schon
sagen weil sie Frau Ministerin die
Kommunen angesprochen haben in Gedanken
haben dafür dass Sie sich jetzt schon
vorbereitet ich weiß nicht ob sie mit
den Kondomen mal gesprochen haben ich
und ich weiß viele Kollegen aus meiner
Funktion haben das auch getan die wissen
überhaupt gar nicht wo Ihnen der Kopf
steht die wissen überhaupt gar nicht
wohin der Kopf steht weil das alles so
lange gedauert hat das ist ja heute
schon so dass in den wohngeldstellen ein
großer Antragsstau ist wenn sich aber
jetzt die Zahl der Wohngeld berechtigen
auf zwei Millionen fast mehr als
verdreifacht dann fehlt es an allem dann
fehlt es am Personal es fehlt an
ausreichenden Büros es fehlt an der
technischen Infrastruktur nichts davon
konnte entsprechend vorbereitet werden
weil einfach keine Klarheit war weil es
jetzt sieben Monate später erst kommt
und deswegen muss man auch klar sagen
wenn das was jetzt geplant ist dass zum
ersten Januar 2023 die wohngeldreform
stehen soll in Kraft treten soll wirken
soll bei den Menschen ankommen soll das
wird
vor aller Voraussicht nach nicht
funktionieren das ist aber dann nicht
die Schuld der Kommunen das ist die
Schuld dieser Bundesregierung die viel
zu spät gehandelt hat meine Damen und
Herren
und ich möchte die Kritik vielleicht
noch an zwei drei Punkten festmachen
weil sie ja im Gesetzentwurf unter
anderem in Aussicht stellen dass das
alles jetzt vorläufig passieren soll
also es sollen vorläufige Auszahlung
gemacht werden ich habe mich dann so ein
bisschen gefragt was ist eigentlich der
Inhalt dieser vorläufigen Prüfung wenn
man mit denjenigen spricht in den
Kommunen die das machen in den Wohngeld
stehen dann sagen die na ja also ich
weiß das auch nicht so richtig die
vorläufige Prüfung entspricht im Kern
eigentlich der endgültigen Prüfung das
bedeutet dann aber eben wieder dass sie
nicht einen Verwaltungsvorgang haben
dass sie einmal gucken hat jemand den
Anspruch auf Wohngeld und dem das dann
aussieht nein sie haben zweimal den
gleichen Vorgang sie müssen erstmal
vorläufig prüfen und es am Ende dann
noch mal endgültig prüfen aber mit dem
gleichen Schemata damit verdoppeln Sie
den Personalaufwand damit verdoppeln Sie
den Aufwand und die verdoppeln damit am
Ende auch die Probleme das ist nicht in
Ordnung damit schaffen sie nur
Verunsicherung meine Damen und Herren
und auch handwerklich und auch
handwerklich hat ihr Vorschlag viele
Mängel ich will das nur mal an der
Systematik der mietenstufen festmachen
die er für die Berechnung des wohngeld
ist ganz zentrales da sagen sie zum
Beispiel das würde es geändert werden da
sagen sie zum Beispiel dass die Stadt
Münster wohin jeder weiß wie die
Wohnungsmarktsituation in einer
Studentenstadt wie Münster ist nämlich
außerordentlich angespannt da sagen sie
Münster das soll gleich behandelt werden
von der Mietenstufe wie Mülheim an der
Ruhr oder wie Pirna das kann man doch
keinem erzählen mal weil man muss doch
nur einmal gucken wie die Mieten
Situation sich dort darstellt das passt
doch überhaupt nicht zusammen das hat
schon was mit Realitätsverweigerung zu
tun was sie ja machen aber mit
Realitätsverweigerung hat die
bauministerin ja spätestens seit dem
Bündnis zu bezahlbaren Wohnort auch ein
bisschen Erfahrung über Monate hat man
das Ziel von 400.000 Wohnungen wie eine
Monstranz vor sich hergetragen jeder
wusste eigentlich dass das nicht
realistisch war hat aber monatelang
trotzdem das aufrechterhalten jahrelang
auf einer falschen Tatsachengrundlage
verhandelt und damit am Ende verhindert
das Richtige und auch schwierige
Entscheidung getroffen waren ich kann
nur sagen beim Wohngeld bei den
mietenstufen wie auch an vielen anderen
Stellen mehr Realität würde dieser Ampel
gut tun meine Damen und Herren und
vielleicht noch einen letzten Punkt den
ich sagen möchte weil der auch mir
wichtig ist eine klimakomponente
einzuführen beim Wohngeld das ist
richtig dass man eine energetischen
Zustand anknüpft das ist richtig dass
man das belohnt wenn ein Vermieter
energetisch saniert und das das
natürlich weil es am Ende eben auch
höhere Mieten bedeutet im Wohngeld sich
widerspiegel müssen auch das ist richtig
nur davon steht in ihrem Gesetz nicht
sie führen zwar eine klimakomponente ein
aber der energetische Zustand eines
Gebäudes also das wo es darauf
eigentlich darauf ankommen sollte bei
der klimakomponente der spielt überhaupt
keine Rolle jeder ganz pauschal kriegt
diesen Zuschlag das ist eine
Mogelpackung genauso wie dieser CO2
Bepreisung was sie jetzt hier als
Vorschlag gemacht haben worüber sie
jetzt in der Ampel streiten das ist eine
Mogelpackung das kann so nicht bleiben
meine Damen und Herren
und deswegen lassen sie mich zum Schluss
nur sagen wir unterstützen als Union
ausdrücklich die Reform des Wohngeldes
wir dürfen die Menschen in dieser
Energiekrise nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen nutzen Sie jetzt diese
verbleibende Wochen mit aller
Ernsthaftigkeit die Einkommen richtig zu
definieren Bagatellgrenzen bei
Rückforderung einzuführen das Klima
Komponenten zu machen die wirklich ihren
Namen verdient damit werden sie dem Lage
dem Ernst der Lage gerecht das was sie
hier vorgelegt haben das wird der Lage
tatsächlich nicht gerecht und deswegen
können wir das so in der Form nicht
mittragen vielen Dank mein Damen und
Herren
Jan marco lucczak war das für die Union
und er kritisiert dass dieses
wohngeldplus-gesetz nicht sozial genug
gestaffelt sei dass jeder
der Anspruch darauf hat egal wie der
Zustand der Wohnung ist oder des Hauses
indem er wohnt Julia verlinken
stellvertreten Fraktionsvorsitzende
ich kann mich an einen Minister ihrer
Partei erinnern der hatte nach Monaten
noch nicht mal einen Staatssekretär
dahingegen haben wir hier ein neues
Bauministerium mit dieser Koalition
gegründet und dieses Bauministerium hat
bereits Anfang des Jahres ein
Heizkostenzuschuss als Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt den wir innerhalb weniger
Wochen hier beschlossen haben und noch
ein paar Wochen später hatten die
Menschen das Geld auf ihrem Konto also
insofern bleiben sie mal bei der
Wahrheit die aktuellen Energiepreise
machen uns allen zu schaffen das ist
klar und es gibt Menschen die sind sehr
viel härter davon betroffen als die
allermeisten hier in diesem Raum und
genau diesen Menschen die hat getroffen
sind weil sie bereits jetzt hohe Mieten
zahlen müssen im Vergleich zu ihrem
Einkommen diesen Empfängerinnen und
Empfängern von Wohngeld die wollen wir
mit diesem Gesetz unter die Arme greifen
aber da hören wir nicht auf wir erhöhen
nicht nur das Wohngeld sondern wir
erweitern auch sehr deutlich den Kreis
der Berechtigten denn die Mieten
explodieren in zahlreichen Städten und
die stellen zum Beispiel Familien vor
große finanziell Herausforderungen trotz
festem Einkommen und zwei Millionen
Haushalte die künftig deswegen das
verbesserte Wohngeld beantragen können
das ist ein richtig großer Fortschritt
das eine Verdreifachung und dafür vielen
herzlichen Dank für den Vorschlag
gleichzeitig bringen wir erneut einen
Heizkostenzuschuss auf den Weg damit
helfen wir den Beziehern von Wohngeld
aber eben auch bafög-empfängerinnen
berufsausbildungsbeihilfen und
Ausbildungsgeld die ampelregierung setzt
so ein klares Zeichen wir lassen die
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen nicht im
Stich und klar ist auch das Wohngeld ist
ein wichtiges soziales und
unverzichtbares Instrument aber es packt
das Problem nicht an der Wurzel
mit dieser Förderung unterstützen wir
natürlich die Menschen die es brauchen
wir finanzieren indirekt aber natürlich
auch die zum Teil viel zu hohen Mieten
in unserem Land und da müssen wir ran
und da gehen wir auch ran und dazu sage
ich Ihnen jetzt gerne was wenn nämlich
noch vorhaben in diesem Richtungswechsel
wir hatten ja beim Thema bezahlbarer
Wohnraum und Sozialwohnungen im Jahr
2006 noch zwei Millionen von diesen beim
Regierungswechsel letztes Jahr waren es
nur noch 1,1 Millionen Sozialwohnungen
und das geht nicht mit mehr sozialen
Wohnungsneubau und einer neuen
wohngemeinnützigkeit können und werden
wir als Ampel gegensteuern und dabei
geht es nicht nur um den Neubau es gibt
zahlreiche Möglichkeiten vorhandene
Gebäude auch besser zu nutzen auszubauen
zu reaktivieren viele Kommunen und
Wohnungsgenossenschaften haben damit
angefangen sie haben zum Beispiel
wohnungstauschprogramme etabliert so
dass zum Beispiel die wachsende Familie
mit der alleinstehenden Dame die Wohnung
unterschiedlicher Größe tauschen kann
sofern dass beide wollen und so nutzen
wir vorhandene Wohnungen Sinn aus auch
anbauen oder beispielsweise
Dachgeschosse ausbauen dort neuen
Wohnraum zu ermöglichen ist ein ganz
wichtiger Beitrag dazu
ressourcenschonend und zügig
zusätzlichen Platz zu schaffen
fossile Heizenergie ist teuer und
widerspricht den Klimazielen im
Gebäudesektor entsteht rund ein Drittel
des gesamten CO2 in Deutschland deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine strukturelle
Veränderung in der Wärmeversorgung das
ist klar die energetische Ertüchtigung
und tiefer gehende Sanierung unserer
Gebäude muss in der Prioritätenliste
weiter nach oben steigen es geht um
Energieeffizienz es geht um erneuerbare
Wärme und nur so können wir die
Mieterinnen und Mieter vor weiteren
Preissteigerungen wirklich nachhaltig
schützen und vermeiden dass der
Heizkostenzuschuss eine Dauerlösung
werden muss und auch dieser Punkt ist im
Wohngeld mitgedacht mit einer
klimakomponente gleichen wir eventuelle
Mietanpassung nach einer Sanierung aus
gleichzeitig unterstützen wir ja auch
die Vermieterinnen und Gebäudeeigentümer
mit zielgerichteten Fördergeldern in der
Gebäudesanierung im Haushalt stellen wir
hierfür
Milliarden in zweistelliger Höhe bereit
weil sie eine sinnvolle Investition sind
so wird ein klimaneutraler
Gebäudebestand ein greifbares Ziel bei
der alle alle Beteiligten mitgenommen
werden und davon profitieren herzlichen
Dank
Julia verlinken war das die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Bündnis grünen um die Bürger bereits
in diesem Jahr angesichts der
gestiegenen Energiekosten zu entlasten
soll es für die Heizperiode von
September bis Dezember einen einmaligen
Heizkostenzuschuss geben er beläuft sich
bei einem Zweipersonenhaushalt zum
Beispiel auf 540 Euro
Roger bekamen jetzt für die AFD erhalten
und die entsprechenden Ausgaben werden
mehr als verdreifacht Wohngeld richtet
sich ein Haushalte mit Einkommen
Altersrenten oder auch Empfänger von
ALG1 bis zu einer bestimmten Höhe wobei
diese Einkünfte für die
wohnkostenbelastung eben nicht
ausreichen inhaltlich geht es bei dieser
Reform Wesentlichen um Heizkosten und
angehobene Einkommensgrenzen all dies
führt dazu dass die Leistungen für
wohngeld-empfänger deutlich erhöhen so
macht allein der neuerdings vorgesehenen
Zuschuss für den Heizkosten rund zwei
Euro 30 je Quadratmeter im Monat gibt es
hier aus
zudem steigt die Zahl der
Anspruchsberechtigten deutlich so bekam
ein
Einpersonenhaushalt bisher Wohngeld bei
einem Einkommen von gut 1.800 Euro
brutto nun darf man sogar 2300 Euro
verdienen und bekommen Wohngeld die
Anzahl der Haushalte die Wohngeld
erhalten steigt damit um 1,4 Millionen
auf dann gut 2 Millionen Haushalte damit
werden auch Teile der unteren
Mittelschicht erreicht und weil das
ganze erst zum ersten Januar 2023 in
krafttritt gibt es noch einmal einen
weiteren Heizkostenzuschuss für
zahlreiche Bezieher von Wohngeld und
anderen Sozialleistungen dieses Jahr
klingt das gut für sie gerade in Zeiten
hoher Inflation und stetig steigende
Energiepreise
aber warum haben wir denn überhaupt so
einen hohen Bedarf an Sozialleistungen
bis in die Mittelschicht denn genau das
ist das Wohngeld eine andere Art der
Sozialhilfe bisher braucht die
menschlich zu etwas nicht wofür ist das
ein Symptom also was liegt dahinter was
sind die Ursachen nun die Nebenkosten
vieler Wohnungsnutzer sind zu hoch diese
bestehen vor allen Dingen aus Heizkosten
die derzeit bekanntermaßen eine Richtung
kennen nach oben wir erinnern uns früher
war alles besser Gasstrom und so weiter
waren bezahlbar die Nachfrage ist zwar
ähnlich wie früher aber das Angebot ist
massiv gesunken also steigen die Preise
die Leute haben wegen des angebots-shops
im Bereich der Energie sowieso schon
weniger Geld in der Tasche und viele
können ihre Steinen Heizkosten nur noch
schwer tragen hier ist wohl eine
gemischte ursachenbilanz festzustellen
also eine Art Putin Habeck Scholz
Gaspreis Pedal daher auch die
gaspreisbremse
und die Mieten nun hier ist genau
andersherum aber mit dem gleichen
Preiseffekt das Angebot ist ähnlich wie
früher aber ihn Nachfrage ist massiv
gestiegen also steigen auch hier die
Preise genannt mieten es gab einen
nachfrageschock so das Wohnungen fehlen
und woher kommt dieser nachfrageschock
Zitat
die Überlastung der Kommunen die
mögliche Überforderung unserer
Sozialsysteme oder eine Begrenzung des
flüchtlingsstromes finden weder im
würdigen noch im Handeln der
Bundesregierung auch nur ansatzweise
Berücksichtigung es ist nicht
nachvollziehbar dass die Bundesregierung
in Zeiten ohnehin hoher zugangszahlen
zusätzliche freiwillige
Aufnahmeprogramme für Flüchtlinge
startet oder mit Leistungsverbesserungen
für Asylbewerber oder mit der Einführung
des sogenannten Chancen
Aufenthaltsrechts noch mehr Anreize
setzt ins Land zu kommen Zitat Ende
könnt ihr das vielleicht stimmen ich
weiß gar nicht genau aber was meinen Sie
das sagte jedenfalls der bayerische
Innenminister Hermann mit Blick auf den
sogenannten flüchtlingsgipfel vor
einigen Tagen Millionen Menschen strömen
abermals derzeit unser Land und wieder
ist Zitat
diese Zuwanderung aus Drittstaaten das
zeigen viele Studien im günstigsten Fall
ein Nullsummenspiel in den meisten
Berechnungen
ist sie ein Kostenfaktor ihrer
Faktenlage pulfaktoren meist geht es um
Flüchtlinge oder um Heiratsmigration das
sind in der Regel eher schlecht
ausgebildete Leute aus Ländern die eine
große wenn ich gar die größte mögliche
kulturelle Distanz zur Europa haben
viele beziehen Sozialleistungen tragen
damit auch nicht im positiven Sinne zu
Gesellschaft und zu Wirtschaft bei Zitat
Ende so Ruth koopmanns Leiter der
Abteilung Migration am
Wissenschaftszentrum für Sozialforschung
in Berlin kürzlich am Beitrag der Neuen
Zürcher Zeitung so viel zu Wissenschaft
bei Damen und Herren
und genau diese Leute bekommen den
Wohnraum den einheimische dringend
brauchen und müssen in der Regel nicht
einmal selbst dafür bezahlen fast
900.000 der Einwanderer ihre Einwanderer
von 2015 und 2016 und Sie können mich da
gerne bescheuerten nennen aber es bleibt
ja ein Fakt beziehen Hartz IV oder
andere Sozialleistungen diesmal hat
Putin damit nicht zu tun das ist allein
Verschulden dieser Regierung und der
Vorgängerregierung
und deswegen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir neben der gaspreisbremse
eine migrationspbremse so einfach kann
es sein denn dieses Land muss sich
ändern von einem Paradies für
asylanwanderer ohne Schutzbedürfnis die
meisten haben gar kein Schutzbedürfnis
muss dieses Land zu einer Wüste für
diese Menschen werden die eben nicht
schutzbedürftig sind das sind wir den
deutschen und allen Einheimischen allen
anderen auch hier die lange gerne hier
leben sollen schuldig nichts aber sind
wir schuldig den Roma-Familien Usbeken
und den tausend anderen Drittstaaten die
die Lage noch keine ausnutzen und über
diese in unser Land kommen und nicht so
die sind wir auch die Hunderttausenden
die aus dem Nahen Osten und Afrika
kommen diese Menschen suchen keinen
Schutz bei uns
diese hätten sie in ihren Nachbarländern
schon längst befinden können nein sie
suchen und finden unserem Land
[Musik]
dank Ihrer Hilfe Staatsbürgerschaften
genau das hält diese Regierung auf
Kosten der einheimischen für Sie bereit
und die eigenen Leute und die eigenen
Leute erhalten dann ein bisschen mehr
Wohngeld als sozialkosmetik herzlichen
Glückwunsch aber ich verrate ihn ein
Geheimnis die Politiker eines Landes
sind zuallererst zum Schutz und Nutzen
des eigenen Landes da und nur mal als
kontrollfrage wie lange wollen Sie das
so weitermachen in Afrika kommen alle 11
Tage alle 11 Tage eine Million Menschen
dazu einfach mal googeln alle 11 Tage
eine Million Menschen kommen dazu die
geboten Raten sind astronomisch alleine
bevölkerungsafrikas verdoppelt sich bis
2050 von 1,2 auf 2,5 Milliarden wie
viele wollen Sie hier davon noch
einladen einige haben bestimmt ein paar
Wohnungen in Ferienhaus bringen Sie doch
gerne zu sich nach Hause und es ist auch
Wahnsinn so hat es doch System wir
subventionieren auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
gegen eine selbstverschuldete
migrationsbedingte Knappheit an ganz
ähnlich wie bei der Energie und genauso
trifft es auch hier eher die Einkommen
schwächeren Teile unseres Volkes diese
Reform des wohngelds mit all ihren
Milliarden ist zwar bitter nötig aber
nur deshalb weil ihre Politik die
entsprechenden Probleme erst
hervorgerufen hat diese Reform ist
letztlich nur ein weiteres Zahnrad im
Reparaturbetrieb ihrer Politik ihre
Politik macht weite Teile unseres Volkes
im Mittelschicht sozialbedürftig ihre
Politik ist zutiefst unmoralisch und
inländerfeindlich sichere Grenzen
bezahlbarer Wohnraum
der Bundestag debattiert über das
wohngeldplus-gesetz und den Heizkosten
Zuschuss und der nächste Redner hier
kommt von der FDP Daniel Vöst Sprecher
für Bau und Wohnungspolitik werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also wie völlig
egal der AFD die akuten Nöte der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Deutschland
sind und wie völlig egal im Herrn
Beckham die akut Nöte sind zeigt er dass
er lieber über Flüchtlinge redet als
über die Sorgen unserer Menschen einzig
an dem Beitrag war es war der einzige
Beitrag der AFD in der Debatte weil wir
sind tatsächlich in schwierigen Zeiten
wir bekommen das ja mit die Menschen
spüren sie haben Angst kann ich Strom
noch zahlen kann ich Heizungen noch
zahlen es ist dringend nötig dass wir
aktiv werden und deswegen handelt ja
auch die ampelregierung wir versuchen
nicht nur Strom zu sparen insbesondere
Industrie sondern wir entlasten auch die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die vor
Überlastung Angst haben und die vor der
Überlastung stehen deswegen kommt ja die
gaspreisbremse deswegen kommt ja den
strompreisbremse deswegen gibt es ja die
energiepreispauschale deswegen werden
auch Steuerentlastungen ausgereicht das
ist ja alles alles richtig und wichtig
und dazu gehört nämlich auch
das Wohngeld deutlich zu erhöhen und
weil die weil die Union mich gerade
fragt wie sieht es denn aus meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren es sieht
leider so aus dass wir als Ergebnis
einer völlig blauäugigen Politik in eine
totale Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas
geraten sind so sieht's aus und ich muss
es jetzt einfach mal hier sagen weil
Frage gestellt wird es
für ein Gas mehr beziehen es ist
vollkommen richtig in keiner Sekunde
stelle ich dieses Sanktionen in Frage
nur wir baden geradeaus was uns
hingelegt wurde also aber zurück zurück
zum Wohngeld ich es tut mir es tut mir
leid ich eigentlich ich versuche es ja
zu vermeiden immer zu erwähnen dass ihr
uns das eingebrockt habt aber ihr
bettelt ja drum ne
so also und jetzt werden wir jetzt
werden wir das Wohngeld deutlich erhöhen
und deutlich ausweiten und wir Freie
Demokraten wir sind bekennende Fans des
wohngelds weil es eine sehr zielgenaue
Hilfe ist weil es genau den Menschen
Hilfe gibt die Hilfe brauchen für die
Dauer in der sie Hilfe brauchen und
deswegen stehen wir mit Begeisterung
hinter diesem Wohngeld ich persönlich
sagt es ist besser den Menschen direkt
zu helfen als allzu viel Geld in Beton
zu verbauen weil was direkt ankommt und
was sofort ankommt für die Dauer in das
benötigt wird ist es besseres System
deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass wir
das Wohngeld zukunftsfit machen das
spielt die heizkostenkomponente
natürlich eine Rolle es ist wichtig die
Heizkosten steigen brauche ich Ihnen
nicht sagen es ist wichtig dass wir die
klimakomponente mit aufnehmen das ist
wichtig und das wichtigste finde ich
ja Herr Lucky
ja doch natürlich wir müssen das müssen
das noch einführen und dann müssen wir
noch Rückzahlung machen und das müssen
sie haben sechs Punkte aufgezählt wo
mehr Bürokratie ins Wohngeld kommt und
beschweren sich dann bei uns dass die
Kommunen es vielleicht nicht leisten
können und natürlich werden wir den
Kommunen und den Ländern helfen müssen
dieses Wohngeld auszuzahlen es ist uns
ja bewusst dass es nicht einfach ist
deswegen haben wir ja oder hat die Frau
Ministerin Entbürokratisierung mit ins
Wohngeld reingepackt deswegen gibt es
die Möglichkeit erstmal
Abschlagszahlungen zu gewähren deswegen
gibt es ja mittlerweile auch das System
eines digitalen wohngeldantrags da frage
ich mich doch in frag mich doch
insbesondere auch als Bayer in Bayern
hessig warum ist in Bayern eine
Wohngeldantrag nicht komplett digital
wir haben mittlerweile ein System dass
man nutzen kann und wenn Kommunen Hilfe
brauchen wir eine digitalisiertes System
bei Google einzuführen bin ich mir
sicher werden wir auch noch Hilfe
leisten können und müssen weil das was
wir jetzt digitalisieren das wird auch
auf Dauer digital bleiben
zum Abschluss
zum Abschluss ein wichtiger Punkt der
Klang auch teilweise eine Debatte schon
an
wir sind in einem System gerutscht und
das ist wirklich bedenklich ich rede
jetzt nicht von den letzten 16 Jahren
aber trotzdem wir sind in ein System
gerutscht das ist bedenklich
es ist fast unmöglich für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft für diejenigen die so
gerade in der Mittelschicht angekommen
sind sich wohnen leisten zu können es
wird immer schwieriger deswegen warten
wir auch das Wohngeld aus aber es kann
ja nicht sein dass wir ein System haben
dass ich entweder auf der einen Seite
beim Bauernhof subventioniere oder auf
der anderen Seite bei den Wohnkosten
hochsubventioniere wir müssen für die
Mitte Gesellschaft ein System haben das
von allein heraus bezahlbaren Wohnraum
schafft und da ist das Bündnis für
bezahlbaren wohnraumfahrtministerin eine
wirklich richtige Antwort wir müssen mit
den Baukosten runter wir müssen mit den
genehmungsverfahren schneller werden wir
müssen schauen dass wir mehr günstiger
und schneller bauen weil wir nicht auf
Dauer einen großen Teil der Gesellschaft
entweder beim Bauen subventionieren
können oder bei wohnsubventionieren
können das Wohngeld ist absolut
notwendig aber damit ist nur der erste
Schritt getan wir werden noch viel mehr
machen müssen damit wir wieder ein
System haben das günstigen Wohnraum aus
sich heraus zur Verfügung stellt vielen
Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen bevor ich
dem nächsten Redner der nächsten
Rednerin das Wort gebe komme ich noch
einmal zurück zum Zusatzpunkt 3 wir
haben das Protokoll geprüft und ich
erteile dem fraktionslosen Abgeordneten
Matthias Helferich einen Ordnungsruf
wir fahren jetzt fort in unserer Debatte
und als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort
Karin live für die Linke
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
die Reform des Wohngeldes ist überfällig
und sie ist dringend nötig deswegen
haben wir das als Linke auch mehrfach
gefordert und konkrete Vorschläge hier
in dieser Stelle eingebracht
deswegen freut es uns dass es endlich
angegangen wird doch leider bleibt ihr
Entwurf unzureichend und Stückwerk
lange Zeit galt es als ungeschriebenes
Gesetz in diesem Land das niemand mehr
als 30 Prozent des Einkommens für das
Wohnen ausgeben muss warm die Realität
ist heute eine andere schon jetzt geben
12 Prozent der Haushalte mehr als 50
Prozent aus kalt mit der Energiekrise
werden es noch deutlich mehr werden
dieser Zustand ist völlig inakzeptabel
niemand darf mehr als 30 Prozent des
Einkommens für das Wohnen ausgeben das
sind die Grundfesten unseres
Sozialstaates und das müsste eine
wohngeldreform auch leisten
aber nein sie machen eine
wohnkostenbelastung von 40% zu Maßstab
und das ist völlig inakzeptabel
und außerdem wird das Wohngeld immer
noch klein gerechnet also wenn man nur
die Mieten der Wohngeld haushaltet zum
Grundlage der Berechnung nimmt also von
Leuten mit sehr wenig Geld dann verzerrt
das doch völlig die Realitäten man
müsste also die Marktmieten zur
Grundlage nehmen und das Ergebnis dieser
kleinen rechten Reihe bedeutet ganz
konkret dass 187 Gemeinden herabgestuft
werden in den sogenannten mietstufen
also zum Beispiel auch Städte wie
Chemnitz oder Bautzen das heißt hier
werden die Zuschüsse praktisch gesenkt
durch ihre Reform das ist doch wirklich
absurd
und wenn sich in der Kritik einen
mietstufen Herr Lutscher von der CDU und
ich einig sind zum ersten Mal nach zehn
Jahren dann müsste ihnen das doch
wirklich zu denken geben
und unsere Kritik die Teilchen nicht nur
den Deutschen Mieterbund sondern auch
der deutschen Städte und gemeindentage
und die sagen lassen Sie uns doch
endlich Zitat die empirisch gefestigten
Grundlagen
einführen zu berechnen der mietstufen
also das ist doch wohl wirklich klar ich
bitte darum
meine Damen und Herren haben Sie schon
mal einen Wohngeldantrag gesehen also es
sind acht komplizierte Seiten fünf
Seiten Erläuterungen 47 Unterpunkte das
überfordert viele Menschen die
Ämter kommen jetzt schon hinterher und
haben nicht das Personal die ihre Reform
umzusetzen
längere bewegungszeiträume das finden
wir gut aber besser wäre es die bereits
bewilligten Anträge zunächst um ein Jahr
zu bewilligen dann könnten sich die
Behörden vollkommen auf die Bearbeitung
der neuen Anträge konzentrieren
immerhin ist salzkostenzuschuss pauschal
das begrüßen wir aber in vielen Decken
deckt er nicht die an vielen Stellen
entdeckte nicht die realen Bedarfe und
was ich wirklich auch dann wirklich
unakzeptabel wir haben ja gleichzeitig
noch den CO2-Preis der immer noch
alleine von den Mieterinnen und Mietern
bezahlt wird das heißt wenn drei
Personen Haushalt mit einer Ölheizung
reduziert sich der Heizkostenzuschuss
dann locker von 640 Euro auf nur noch
450 Euro also das reicht doch dann bei
weitem nicht aus
meine Damen und Herren das
grundsätzliche Problem kann keine
wohnweltreform leisten nämlich
mietenwahn sind und Spekulation viele
beziehende von Wohngeld die wohnen doch
bei vonovia bei LED bei den großen
privaten Konzernen und denen schmeißen
wir jetzt natürlich mit so einer Reform
das Geld am Ende des Tages auch noch
hinterher deswegen kann eine
wohngeldreform nicht das einzige und
auch nicht das zentrale Instrument sein
wir brauchen endlich einen mietenstopp
lassen Sie uns das Problem bei den
Wurzeln packen
deswegen brauchen wir ein Krisenpaket
Miete das heißt schutzverkündigungen
Schutz vor Zwangsräumungen Verbot von
indexmieten und ja wir brauchen einen
mietendeckel und einen Deckel für Strom
und Gaspreise das fordern wir als LINKE
das hilft gegen Spekulation gegen
Inflation und kommt den Staat auch nicht
zu teuer zu stehen vielen Dank
Karin leiert mal gerechnet von der
Linken Sprecherin für Mieten Bau und
Wohnungspolitik die nächste Rednerin
kommt von der SPD ist die zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Verena Huberts
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau bauministerin Gallwitz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden
heute hier über eine große
wohngeldreform aber was sind das
eigentlich für Menschen für die wir das
tun und mein Wahlkreis das ist Trier und
da gibt es auch einige denen diese
Reform zugute kommt es gibt zum Beispiel
den Rentner der hat damals so viel
verdient dass er sich jetzt nicht
unbedingt viel sparen konnte für die
Rente und der zahlt 500 Euro kalt in
einem Trierer Stadtteil nicht mal
Innenstadtlage und gibt mehr als die
Hälfte seiner Rente für die Miete aus
es gibt die alleinerziehende Mutter und
viele können nur ahnen wie
herausfordernd das Leben ist wenn man
natürlich dann auch in Teilzeit arbeitet
und damit nicht oder nur mit Mühe und
Not über die Runden kommt und das sind
Lebensrealitäten für viele Menschen in
unserem Land das sind Leute die hart
arbeiten und die hart gearbeitet haben
und für diese Leute machen mehrere Euro
mehrere hundert Euro im Monat den
Unterschied auch aus den Unterschied
zwischen einem selbstbestimmten Leben
oder den Abrutsch in Sozialleistungen
und für mich ist es auch eine Frage des
Respekts worüber wir ja heute reden denn
diejenigen die hart arbeiten in unserem
Land die sollen nicht aus ihrer Wohnung
fliegen weil sie sich die Miete und die
Nebenkosten nicht mehr leisten können
und nicht nur in der Krise sondern
dauerhaft und dafür ist das Wohngeld da
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir erweitern den bezirkreis wir
verdreifachen ihnen von 600.000 auf über
2 Millionen Haushalte und wir steigern
auch die Summe und wir haben es eben
gehört von der bauministerin es wird
eine dauerhafte heizkomponente geben wir
werden mit einer klimakomponente
sicherstellen dass sich insbesondere
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen nicht
dann die schlechtesten Wohnungen mehr
leisten können sondern dass auch dafür
ein Faktor eingepreist ist und ganz
wichtig und dafür sind wir heute auch
hier wir müssen auch kommunikativ an das
Wohngeld ran viele wissen auch nicht
dass sie Anspruch haben oftmals ist es
noch in der sogenannten Schmuddelecke
und man hat Befindlichkeiten und möchte
da auch nicht unbedingt hingehen und
diesen Antrag den wir eben auch gesehen
haben der auch einfacher werden darf und
wird auszufüllen und ich finde jemand
der arbeitet der sich an die Regeln hält
in diesem Land und der trotzdem nicht
über die Runden kommt diese Menschen
haben Anspruch auf Solidarität
und ja wir haben eben viel geredet über
Symptome über den Wohnungsmarkt und wir
sind uns dessen bewusst dass wir hier
mit einem Symptom bekämpfen aber wir
gehen doch natürlich auch ran an die
Wurzel des Problems vielleicht hat der
einen oder andere ja gestern mitbekommen
dass wir da drüben im Kanzleramt
gemeinsam waren mit einem Bündnis ein
Bündnis bezahlbares Wohnen dort haben
wir 67 Seiten an Maßnahmen festgelegt
damit wir jetzt ins bauen kommen und
damit es einfacher wird und damit wir
natürlich auch weiteren bezahlbaren
Wohnraum schaffen in diesem Land und
jetzt erzählen sie nicht dass wir hier
nur ein bisschen kleinkosmetik nein wir
packen das Thema Wohnen ganzheitlich an
mit einem Ministerium gemeinsam in
dieser Koalition mit Wumms und mit einem
Bündnis aus vielen Maßnahmen und vor
allen Dingen aus einem Bündnis mit
vereinten Kräften liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und ja wir haben auch im
Koalitionsvertrag einiges vereinbart
und wir haben auch noch einiges vor und
ich bin auch sehr dankbar dass der
Kollege von der FDP Buschmann mit
Hochdruck dran arbeitet dass wir auch
die mietrechtlichen Fragestellungen
gemeinsam hinbekommen denn da haben wir
natürlich auch noch jede Menge zu tun
aber wenn wir anders Wohngeld gehen wenn
wir an das Bauen gehen von bezahlbaren
Wohnraum und wenn wir eben jetzt auch
dieses Maßnahmenbündel auf den Weg
bekommen dann bin ich optimistisch dass
wir hier niemanden alleine lassen dass
wir es gemeinsam anpacken dafür danke
ich für die konstruktive Mitarbeit und
ich sage legen wir los
das Wort erhält für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Michael Kiesling
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Fürst ich
möchte mal darauf eingehen zur
blauäugigen Energiepolitik wir haben gut
gelebt von den günstigen Energiepreisen
und Herr Scholz wusste ja schon immer
dass Putin sozusagen die Energie
verwenden wird um Krieg zu führen und
entsprechend Einfluss zu nehmen er war
damals Arbeitsminister war
Vizekanzler und Finanzminister den Kurs
mitgetragen am Anfang von Kanzler also
Kanzler wurde hat auch die notstring 2
noch verteidigt und mir scheint so sie
wissen heute schon die Fehler diese du
morgen machen testen wenn ich blaue
blauäugige Politik aber zurück
zum Thema Wohngeld Wohngeld das ist
richtig dass man es erhöht dass man es
ausbaut und das mater reformiert es ist
wichtig dass wir auf die aktuellen
Herausforderungen Antworten
Jan Marquardt lukas hat angesprochen es
kommt zu spät wir haben sie im März
bereits gefordert die Leute sind jetzt
natürlich auf der Palme und sagen wie
soll ich das denn in Zukunft Zahlen es
soll jetzt anfangen des nächsten Jahres
umgesetzt werden die Kommunen sind nicht
vorbereitet weder vom Personal noch wie
es funktionieren will es fehlt einfach
die Planungssicherheit und das fehlt der
Vorlauf das auch entsprechender Zeit
abzuarbeiten und wenn sie auch im
Gespräch sind wie wir mit den
verschiedenen Ebenen im Land und in den
Kommunen dann würden sie ihnen das auch
bestätigen dass es so ist und das ist
die Herausforderung die wir haben sie
müssen schauen dass wir das schnell sind
und die handwerklichen Fehler die dort
noch drin sind auch schnell behoben
werden so dass man das auch entsprechend
schnell auszahlen kann und verlässlich
auszahlen kann
die Erwartungen die sie führen das
angefangen vom 9-euro-ticket was nicht
langfristig durchgeführt werden kann bis
jetzt beim Wohngeld ist immer sie
kündigen an
sie liefern nicht sie liefern zu spät
oder es bleiben Fragen offen und das
denke ich ist nicht die Politik die wir
in Krisenzeiten benötigen
auch die endgültige Finanzierungs ist ja
noch etwas offen auch das müsste man
lernen und dass wir eine Verdreifachung
der Berechtigten haben ist erstmal eine
gute Zahl dass mir ausgewiesen ist aber
eigentlich ist es erschütternd das wäre
dreifache Verdoppelung haben der
wohngeld-empfänger es müsste ich
eigentlich lohnen wenn man ein
Arbeitgeht dass man sich sozusagen mit
dem Geld was man verdient die Wohnung
die Wärme den Strom und auch des Leben
leisten kann und das sehe ich bei ihrer
Koalition überhaupt nicht gegeben das
scheint auch nicht der Anspruch ihrer
Regierung zu sein
durch die Links FDP geführte Regierung
wird es ja gerade zum Anspruch nicht zu
arbeiten
wenn man auf das Bürgergeld schaut
beispielsweise ja nichts a das haben sie
verbrochen oder wollen es Verbrechen
wenn ich nicht arbeite und dadurch mehr
Geld bekomme als wenn ich in die Arbeit
gehe dann habe ich doch ein Problem dann
rentiert sich es doch gar nicht wenn die
Arbeitsergebnis doch der falsche Anreiz
meine Damen und meine Herren
wer in die Arbeit geht der soll auch von
diesem Geld leben können und dieser
Lohnabstand und Leistungsabstand der
muss doch auch entsprechend dargestellt
werden meine Damen und Herren
so und wir haben doch die
gesellschaftliche Verantwortung zu
rechtfertigt das mit dem Geld dass wir
von den Steuern zahlen einnehmen auf
verantwortungsvoll umgehen und auch die
nachfolgende Generationen entsprechend
bezahlen und entgegen der Meinung vor
dem einordnen grünen Abgeordneten kann
sich der Staat nicht grenzenlos
verschulden und die Zinsen selber
festlegen
Wirtschaftspolitik scheint nicht die
Stärke der Grünen zu sein meine Damen
und Herren
und damit handeln sie nicht nachhaltig
nachhaltig ist nicht nur Umwelt und
Klimaschutz nachhaltig ist auch eine
solide Haushaltspolitik und eine faire
Sozialpolitik und dies für die die das
Geld erwirtschaften und diejenige die
wir solidarisch entsprechend
unterstützen müssen meine Damen und
Herren
lassen Sie mich abschließend noch auf
einen Punkt eingehen das Wohngeld ist
ein Bestandteil unser wichtiger
Bestandteil ohne Frage es ist
zielgerichtet weil es auf den Bedarf des
Einzelnen entsprechend eingeht auf die
Größe der Wohnung auf das Einkommen und
so weiter aber wir brauchen auch
Wohnraum und das haben sie geschafft
innerhalb kürzester Zeit eine vollbremse
eine glatte Vollbremsung Wohnungsmarkt
zu verursachen wir haben hohe Baukosten
wir haben hohe Energiekosten da fehlen
momentan die Antworten von der Regierung
wie reagieren Sie darauf was kann mir
entsprechend anbieten sie schrauben die
anforderungene Wohnungsbau hoch und
streichen die Förderprogramme zusammen
sie vertröst mit einem lauwaren Ergebnis
des Bündnis was sie gestern vorgestellt
haben wenn wir zurückblicken hat man
Hochlauf auf 300.000 Wohnungen gebaut
worden
wir hatten Baukindergeld wir hatten
depressive AfA wir hatten KfW-Förderung
jetzt fordern sie 400.000 Wohnungen und
das ganze soll funktionieren mit einem
förderchaos aller Habeck mit steigenden
Zins mit lieferengkreis mit steigen
Baukosten das glauben nicht mal ihre
Bündnispartner die gestern entsprechend
das Bündnis mit vorgestellt haben
momentan wird sie haben sie gesagt die
400.000 Wohnungen werden nicht mehr
erreichen aber sie stehen im
bündnispapier nach wie vor drin anstatt
klare Konzepte und gezielte investive
Maßnahmen wollen sie mit prüfauftragen
Evaluation runden Tischen den
wohnungsbaufördern das klingt schön aber
damit wird keine neuen Wohnungen und
zumindest nicht schnell neue Wohnungen
gebaut die wir brauchen
und eins noch sie haben völlig
rechtschreibitz wenn es im bauwumms
macht dann ist was kaputt dann hat was
nicht funktioniert sie machen einen
doppelwurf sie fahren die Bauwirtschaft
gegen die Wand herzlichen Dank
oh und jetzt kommt Hann
ah starkes 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kiessling
ich habe wirklich versucht so zu hören
und es ging ja um 9 Euro Ticket
Bürgergeld zwei buntes potpouri zum
Wohngeld habe ich nicht so viel gehört
deswegen probiere ich jetzt noch mal mit
dem hohen Geld worum es ja eigentlich in
diesem Job geht
wir wollen sozial gemischte Kieze das
Wohngeld wurde bereit eingeführt um
genau das zu ermöglichen damit Menschen
mit niedrigem Einkommen sich auf dem
freien Wohnungsmarkt eine Wohnung
leisten können und da wohnen wo sie
wollen das ist die Idee des Wohngeldes
und die gilt noch immer auch wenn wir
jetzt zu Recht ganz viel Entlastung
diskutiert haben und die Folgen von
Putins angriffskriegs die zu steigenden
Energiepreisen und anderen
Preisexplosionen führen also beim
Wohngeld geht es darum dass wir
sozial gemischte kiezer erhalten und wir
haben die größte wohngeldreform der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik von ihr
profitieren zwei Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland zwei Millionen Haushalt in
ganz Deutschland Rentnerin
Alleinerziehende Familien Studierende
Azubis und Menschen mit kleinem
Einkommen
mit Verena Hubert sind wir gerade schon
nach Trier gegangen ich würde meinen
Berlin bleiben was bedeutet das Wohngeld
konkret das bedeutet für die Rentnerin
in Berlin die eine Miete von 550 Euro
hat und ein Gesamteinkommen von 1.200
Euro sie hat bisher Anspruch auf 16 Euro
Wohngeld sehr berechtigt können nur
davon ausgehen dass sie das vermutlich
nicht beantragt hat der Aufwand steht in
kein Verhältnis zu 16 Euro im Monat das
heißt wahrscheinlich nutzt sie es nicht
nach der Reform bekommt sie 212 Euro
Wohngeld das ist fast die Hälfte ihrer
Miete
und wir wandern weiter bei Berlin ja
nicht der Nabel der Republik ist für die
Familien Heidelberg zwei Elternteile ein
Kind Miete 900 Euro Einkommen 2.800 Euro
brutto sie haben bisher keinen Anspruch
auf Wohngeld nach der Reform sind es 311
€. es macht also einen Unterschied es
bedeutet das auch ich gucke zu meinen
Kollegen Kassen hinterher sali die
alleinerziehende in Dresden
beispielsweise sichere Wohnungen noch
leisten kann und nicht umziehen muss das
ist eine ganz wichtige Veränderung durch
die Reform des wohngelds
aber es ist heute die erste Lesung des
wohngeldreformgesetzes Gesetzes gilt das
erst drucksche Gesetz auch wir möchten
noch einige Dinge ändern das eine wurde
heute schon vielfach thematisiert die
Frage wie wir es schaffen dass wir die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Wohngeld stellen die wirklich wichtige
Arbeit leisten nicht überfordern da
müssen wir gemeinsam als Ampel noch mal
überlegen es gibt viele Vorschläge dass
wir das noch einfacher machen das sind
wir die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern schuldig
und ich als grüne habe noch einen
zweiten Punkt
so wie die klimakomponente in diesem
Gesetzesentwurf ausgestaltet ist hat sie
mit einem sozialen Ausgleich für
energetische Sanierung noch nicht so
viel zu tun ich verstehe wir sind in
einer Situation dass wir sehr schnell
die Reform durchbringen möchten müssen
weil wir sehr schnell Menschen entlasten
wollen das ist richtig aber ich finde
wir müssen trotzdem noch mal überlegen
was man da drehen kann oder notfalls bei
der nächsten Evaluierung eine
klimakomponente einführen die ihrem
Namen dann auch wirklich gerecht wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Ziel beim Wohngeld ist es dass die
soziale Mischung erhalten bleibt dafür
nehmen wir ehrlich gesagt ganz schön
viel Geld in die Hand um Mieten zu
subventionieren aber es gibt auch andere
Wege dieses Ziel zu erreichen und an
denen müssen wir genauso arbeiten wir
brauchen eine neue wohngemeinnützigkeit
damit wir dauerhaft bezahlbaren Wohnraum
zur Verfügung stellen und
und wir müssen das
Vorkaufsrecht wieder rechtssicher
einführen damit Mieterinnen und Mieter
nicht weiter verdrängt werden dafür
werden wir uns Grüne in der Koalition
weiter einsetzen und ich freue mich auf
die Beratung von Heizkostenzuschuss und
wohngeldplus-
vielen Dank Hannah Steinmüller war das
für die Bündnisgrünen der nächste Redner
in dieser Debatte die nächste Rednerin
ist eine König von der cdu/csu
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast auf den
Tag genau vor sieben Monaten durfte ich
hier im Deutschen Bundestag meine erste
Rede zum Heizkostenzuschuss halten seit
Anfang März ist viel Zeit vergangen und
immer noch warten die Menschen in
unserem Land auf strukturelle und
spürbare Entlastung schon damals haben
wir als Union erklärt dass ihre
einmalhilfen der Wirklichkeit
hoffnungslos hinterherhinken und bei
einer immer weiter steigenden Preisen
die Kosten auch der Menschen nur minimal
abfedern ich habe im März schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die Preisexplosion
längst die gesellschaftliche Mitte
erreicht hat und es eben nicht nur
symbolische Hilfen für wenige sondern
strukturelle Lösungen für viele braucht
denn schon damals war klar dass ein
einmaliger Heizkostenzuschuss nicht
reichen wird und das ist einer
wohngeldreformbedarf mit einer inte
alten Klima und heizkostenkomponente und
es ist für die Menschen in diesem Land
bitter dass die allermeisten
Kritikpunkte aus dem Frühjahr heute noch
genauso zutreffend und aktuell sind wie
vor sieben Monaten denn ihre
Herangehensweise hat sich seitdem nicht
verbessert und eine Lernkurve ist bei
ihnen mit bloßem Auge auch nicht zu
erkennen aber
fangen aber fangen wir mal bei der
Wurzel des Problems an diese
Bundesregierung weigert sich hartnäckig
die Angebotsseite in der gebotenen
Konsequenz zu erhöhen und ihr ist es
nicht gelungen in sieben Monaten einen
Vorschlag auf europäischer Ebene zu
unterbreiten wie man Gas aus dem Berit
order-system rausnimmt somit bleiben
Strom und Gaspreise bis auf weiteres
Hoch hinzu kommt experten sagen uns seit
Monaten voraus dass uns eine schwere
Rezession droht man kann nur hoffen dass
ihr sogenannter doppelwumms für
Industrie und Mittelstand nicht zum
doppelflop wird irgendwer muss in
Zukunft die auch unsere Sozialleistungen
erwirtschaften und wir können nur mit
einer starken Wirtschaft unseren
Wohlstand erhalten
zur Zeit vergrößert ihre Politik nicht
nur den ökonomischen Schaden sondern
führt auch zu gesamtgesellschaftlichen
und sozialen Verwerfungen denken Sie
bitte auch mal darüber nach was sollen
eigentlich all diejenigen die arbeiten
gehen und keinen Wohngeld und keinen
Heizkostenzuschuss erhalten jetzt tun
auch die Unterstützung für die
arbeitende Mitte ist jetzt notwendiger
denn je
zudem braucht es für Geringverdiener und
Rentner die eben knapp oberhalb des
empfängerkreises liegen ebenfalls
Lösungen alles andere wäre ungerecht da
es sich heute um die erste Lesung
handelt und wie die Regierung im
Interesse der Menschen kritisch
konstruktiv begleiten wollen will ich
Ihnen gerne die wichtigsten Kritikpunkte
noch mal darlegen und ich tue das auch
in der Hoffnung dass sie diese dieses
Mal auch aufgreifen und endlich
Verbesserungen vornehmen erstens sowohl
der Heizkostenzuschuss als auch das
wohngeldplus in ihrer jetzigen Form
behandeln höchstens die Symptome das
Problem muss an der Wurzel gepackt
werden erweitern Sie also das
Energieangebot und reduzieren Sie
dadurch die Preise zweitens lösen sie
zumindest bei diesem Gesetz einmal ihr
Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
ein da heißt es nämlich richtigerweise
auf Seite 8 wir wollen Gesetze
verständlicher machen
stattdessen konfrontieren Sie nun den
Bürger mit folgender Formulierung aus
Anlage 3 ich zitiere das unberundete
monatliche Wohngeld ergibt sich durch
Einsetzen der Werte für ABC aus Anlage 2
und für m und Y in die Formel nach § 19
Absatz 1 Satz 1 und durch Ausführen der
vier folgenden Rechenschritte Z1 = A+B
mal m und + C * y Z2 = Z1 mal y Z3 = m -
Z2 und Z4 = 1,15 * Z3 und ich sage Ihnen
ganz ehrlich damit provozieren sie
wahrscheinlich hunderttausende Anrufe
bei den wohngeldstellen vor Ort weil
niemand bei ihrem Gesetz weiß ob ihm
Wohngeld plus überhaupt zusteht sorgen
Sie da auch bitte für Klarheit
drittens insbesondere der
Heizkostenzuschuss erscheint nicht
zielgenau der festgelegte Betrag kann
sowohl in die eine als auch in die
andere Richtung stark vom tatsächlichen
Preis zum Zeitpunkt des Bedarfs
abweichen da entstehen Ungerechtigkeiten
mit Ansage während es für den einen Teil
der Empfänger ein auskömmlicher Zuschuss
sein kann weil sie gegebenenfalls in
einem energetisch guten Gebäude wohnen
wissen andere immer noch nicht wie sie
die Preisexplosion mit der Einmalzahlung
Schultern sollen wenn sie die
Betroffenen nicht zielgenauer
bezuschussen können Sie quasi jetzt
schon über das nächste
nachbesserungsgesetz nachdenken und
viertens bedauerlicherweise ist das Geld
mit der Verabschiedung von Gesetzen ja
auch noch lange nicht bei den Bürgern
der Aufgaben Zuwachs bei den
wohngeldbehörden führt durch die
Verdreifachung der Anträge zu langen
Wartezeiten pro Erstantrag für Wohngeld
werden laut ihren Ausführungen 92
Minuten benötigt und ich warne davor die
zu erwartende Antragsflut auf dem Rücken
der Mitarbeiter in den Behörden
auszutragen eine Bundes Regierung die
ihren personalkörper so schamlos
aufgestockt hat wie die ihre muss es
jetzt schaffen die wohngeldbehörden
durch umschichten und Abgeordneten von
Personal auch wirksam zu unterstützen
im übrigen braucht es auch hier eine
echte digitalisierungsoffensive damit
das Geld schneller bei den Menschen
ankommt abschließend sei gesagt handeln
sie vor allem weitsichtig sieben Monate
mussten vergehen bis sie wieder tätig
wurden und jetzt sind wir schon längst
in der Heizperiode nehmen Sie die
notwendigen Verbesserung an ihrem
Gesetzentwurf im Interesse der Menschen
vor dann sind wir auch gerne bereit
zuzustimmen aber zu einem weiter so in
ihrer unausgegorenen und unzureichenden
Krisenpolitik werden wir keinen Beitrag
leisten vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
ja mal ganz beeindruckend so ein
Gesetzestext vorgelesen zu bekommen
Sandra Weser jetzt Vorsitzende im
Ausschuss für Wohnen Stadtentwicklung
bauen und Kommunen von der FDP
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Union sie haben ja jetzt
16 Jahre lang in der Bundes-
aber ich kann es Ihnen ehrlich gesagt
nicht ersparen sie regieren in acht
Bundesländern mit sie stellen hier in
diesem Land ein ganz ordentlichen Anteil
an Landräten an Bürgermeister an
Amtsleitern und dann stellen Sie sich
hier hin Herr Kiesling
und sagen und beklagen dass die Ämter
überfordert sind und dass sie nicht in
der Lage werden den Rentnern den
Teilzeitkräften den Studenten und den
Azubis in diesem Land das Wohngeld
auszuzahlen da müssen wir uns doch die
Frage stellen warum ist das denn so ja
weil sie weil sie wenn sie im
politischer Verantwortung sind keine
Modernisierung und auch keine Reform
dieser Verwaltungen angehen und weil die
Union die Digitalisierung im Bund
komplett verschlafen hat und in den
Ländern und in den Kommunen weiterhin
verschläft und sie blockieren sie auch
noch zusätzlich ja und weil ihre
Ministerpräsidentin und Präsident nichts
besseres einfällt als immer mehr nach
Steuergeld zu rufen anstatt vielleicht
auch meinem eigenen Laden effizient
aufzuräumen eins ist doch ganz klar
die Ausweitung des Wohngeldes von
600.000 Haushalten auf zwei Millionen
das ist kein Klax das ist eine
Riesenherausforderung aber es ist eben
auch ein Grund jetzt anzupacken nicht
einfach nur Hände in den Schoß sondern
jetzt heizt auch mal Ärmel hochkrempeln
auch in den Ländern und hier zählt auch
ein Stück weit die Eigenverantwortung es
gibt Lösungen unter fdp-regierungsarbeit
Herr Völs hat es eben schon mal erwähnt
haben wir 2019 in Schleswig-Holstein ein
komplett digitales Verfahren zur
Beantragung von Wohngeld für alle
Bundesländer zur Verfügung gestellt
und jetzt schauen wir mal nach Bayern
zum Herrn Kießling da gibt es ein paar
Landkreise die nutzen das aber selbst
drei Jahre später ist es auch nur ein
Bruchteil der frage ich mich regiert
denn da in Bayern und hätten sie jetzt
nicht die letzten 16 Jahre geschlafen
dann hätten wir heute diese moderne
digitale Verwaltung und dann könnten wir
jetzt in dieser Krise irgendwookratisch
und auch schnell helfen geht aber leider
nicht und ich will jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen die Meter Ebene ansprechen wir
haben in Estland ein Leuchtturm wir
können das sehen dass alle relevanten
Daten in diesem Land ob das Einkommen
ist ob das Anzahl der Kinder ist die
Sozialleistung die Kontoverbindung alle
schon längst in einem zentralen
digitalen bürgerkonto erfasst sind und
dort kann man einfach mit einem
online-eintrag jede staatliche Leistung
beantragen und die werden dann auch
online geprüft und sowas brauchen wir
hier auch in Deutschland und wir
brauchen hier einen zentrales digitales
bürgerkonto und wo wir im Prinzip dauern
dem anstatt den Wohngeldantrag noch mal
per papierfirma auszufüllen einfach dann
digital reinstellen und innerhalb von
einer halben Stunde auch genehmigt
bekommen das wäre der Weg den wir gerne
gehen würden vor allen Dingen die FDP
und ich denke mal da kommen wir hin wenn
alle Bundesländer mitziehen und wenn wir
uns nicht immer wieder auf diese
ineffiziente Kleinstaaterei zurückziehen
würden
als ersten Schritt in die richtige
Richtung sollte wir hier
Parallelstrukturen abbauen das heißt
Verwaltungen Auszahlung von Wohngeld
zusammenlegen mit der Grundsicherung das
heißt eine Behörde ein Datensatz ein
digitales bürgerkonto und die Kommunen
wären soeben von den wohngeldanträgen
auch entlastet das heißt diese Menschen
die dann entlastet würden die könnten
sich vielleicht auch mal um die
Baugenehmigung für neue Wohnungen
kümmern wäre auch effizient und das
heißt im Ernst also das kleine Estland
macht es uns doch hier jetzt wirklich
vor und wenn die Ministerpräsidenten im
Land wirklich mal diesen Weg gehen
würden dem Bund die Kompetenzen für ein
digitales bürgerkonto zu übertragen dann
fliege ich persönlich morgen mit ihnen
nach Estland und dann fragen wir Opfer
da eben auch die Software zur Verfügung
gestellt bekommen herzlichen Dank
Sandra Wieser war das für die FDP
den nächste Redner rein Niklas Nicoles
von der SPD
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren vielleicht
eine kurze Vorbemerkung vorab ich schäme
mich nicht links zu sein und links zu
sitzen ich würde mich aber schämen wie
Sie Herr Kießling sich hier den
Antidemokraten im Parlament anzubiedern
mit solchen äußern die Sie getätigt
haben
Wohngeld und Bürgergeld gehören zusammen
und wir haben ja noch etwas
parlamentarische Beratungszeit um das zu
verdeutlichen mit dem Wohngeld haben wir
ein wirksames sozialpolizistinstrument
es sorgt direkt und zielgenau für
Entlastungen
48 Prozent der aktuell wohngeldbeben
sind Rentnerinnen 40% sind Familien
davon viele Alleinerziehende mit der
Reform haben wir genau diese Menschen im
Blick
ein Rentner in Berlin muss von seinen
von seiner kleinen Rente hier leben eine
vierköpfige Familie in Tübingen muss
ihre Wohnung bezahlen mit 1000 Euro
Kaltmiete
ein alleinstehende Friseurin zum
Beispiel Datteln arbeitet Vollzeit und
verdient jetzt 12 Euro den neuen
Mindestlohn was haben all diese Personen
gemeinsam
auf den ersten Blick vielleicht nicht so
viel doch sie alle haben ein kleines
Einkommen ihnen allen helfen
Steuersenkungen nicht sie alle werden
jetzt dank des wohngeldpluses dauerhaft
und kräftig entlastet bei dem Wohnkosten
die Familien Tübingen hat jetzt Anspruch
auf über 800 Euro Wohngeld im Monat also
über 300 Euro mehr im Monat als vorher
der Rentner erhält bisher rund 75 Euro
künftig sind es 250 Euro im Monat und
die alleinstehende Friseurin sie erhält
mit dem wohngeldplus-gesetz jetzt
erstmal einen Wohngeldanspruch und mit
dem Wohngeldrechner ist das leicht zu
überprüfen
genau für diese Menschen ist das
Wohngeld da das Wohngeld ist ein
Wohnkostenzuschuss für Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen egal ob sie zum
Mieter wohnen oder im Wohneigentum
Menschen die trotz harter Arbeit am Ende
des Monats an den hohen Wohnkosten
verzweifeln Menschen die sich diesen
Anspruch auf Wohngeld erarbeitet haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Menschen zu entlasten ist eine Frage des
Respekts
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir nun das
Wohngeld Plus auf dem Weg bringen es ist
ein Teil von vielen milliardenschweren
Maßnahmen die unsere Regierung unter
oder Scholz auf dem Weg gebracht hat
ich wünschte ich wünschte dass ich die
Landesregierung meines Bundeslandes NRW
daran auch mal ein Beispiel nimmt in der
Krise heißt es machen statt meckern oder
zumindest nicht im Weg stehen wenn der
Bund vorangeht
und und der Kollege Lucia hat jetzt hier
viel gesagt was schneller gehen muss was
anders geben muss aber ich habe keinen
einzigen konkreten Vorschlag gehört wir
das eigentlich machen möchte außer ein
ein Forscher kann ich gehört wie das
halt bei der klimakomponente noch
komplizierter wird und noch länger zu
prüfen ist das ist ein
Widersprüchlichkeit nicht zu überbieten
meine Damen und Herren
für die schnelle und ambitionierte und
wichtige Erarbeitung des
Gesetzesentwurfs danke ich unsere
Ministerin und dem gesamten Haus
herzlich meine Vorrednerinnen haben die
wichtigen Verbesserungen schon
ausführlich dargestellt
heizkostenkomponente klimakomponente und
eine Erhöhung der Leistung das alles
kommt rein ohne dass das
Antragsverfahren komplexer wird
zentral ist auch die massive Ausweitung
der Leistungsberechtigten rund 2
Millionen Haushalte können zukünftig das
Wohngeld beantragen es ist ein
wesentlicher Baustein zur Abfederung der
Krise dafür ist es entscheidend dass das
Geld direkt bei den Menschen ankommt
und deshalb nehmen all den guten Dingen
die schon drin sind die wir hier in
Berlin beschließen vor allem die
Umsetzung vor Ort
ich habe in den letzten Wochen auch wie
einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
angesprochen haben auch mit der Praxis
gesprochen in dem wohngeldstellen
Gespräche geführt und ich verstehe dass
durch die vielen Neuanträge im nächsten
Jahr weitere Arbeit auf sie zukommt
deswegen sind zwei Dinge jetzt ganz
wichtig
erstens wir alle sind uns einig es
braucht Vereinfachung damit Anträge
schneller geprüft werden können und das
Geld schneller bei den Menschen ankommen
da sind aber Bund und Länder gemeinsam
in der Pflicht wir werden hier genau
hinsehen und prüfen welche
praxistauglichen Vereinfachungen noch
möglich sind
zweitens wir brauchen in dem
wohngeldstellen eine vernünftige
personelle Ausstattung und hier geht
mein Appell ganz besonders an die Länder
sie müssen doch ihre Kommunen in die
Lage versetzen Stellen zu schaffen und
zu besetzen
denn es ist klar zum erfolgreichen
Umsetzung dieser Reform müssen wir alle
an einem Strang ziehen und ich hoffe
dass das im parlamentarischen Verfahren
noch gelingt wird
zum Schluss liegt mir eine Sache
besonders am Herzen wir befreien das
Wohngeld mit diesem Gesetz vom
verstaubten Image liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger machen sie Gebrauch von ihrem
Anspruch sie haben sich den Anspruch
erarbeitet und verdient und wer was
anderes sagt macht Politik auf Kosten
auf ihre Kosten und das finde ich
schäbig herzlichen Dank
ja als auf das Wohnmobil zu verzichten
das sollte man in der Tat nicht tun 540
Euro sind das für einen zwei
Personenhaushalt
Anja nein
vielen Dank dass ich so oft erwähnt
haben ich glaube ich bin keiner
Bundestagsdebatte ist auf der Welt
worden wie in dieser aber zu ihrer
möchte ich schon noch was sagen was ist
falsch an den Wunsch die Menschen aus
den Sozialleistungen zu führen und dass
die vor dem selbstverdienten Geld auch
leben können das muss doch unser
Anspruch sein ich muss doch unser
Anspruch sein dass ich wenn ich Geld
verdiene das sind Arbeitsplatz habe und
davon leben kann das hat doch nicht mit
rechts und links zu tun das muss doch
der Anspruch sein einer demokratisch
gewählten Partei dass sich Leistung
lohnen muss
möchten sie reagieren bitte sehr
gehe ich sehr gerne ich habe sie an
einer Stelle angesprochen genau das ist
richtig und ich glaube sie haben
verkannt an welchem Punkt ich sie
angesprochen habe ich finde es
unanständig die bürgergeldiskussion in
diesem Kontext einzubringen als würden
wir eben die Menschen die hart arbeiten
dadurch benachteiligen ich frage mich
warum haben Sie nicht zugestimmt als es
um den Mindestlohn ging wo man ganz
konkret hätte helfen können das was Sie
angesprochen haben in Realität
umzusetzen und entschuldigen Sie aber
wenn Sie den sprech der AFD übernehmen
dann benenne ich das ganz deutlich und
dann dann dann tut es mir leid ich habe
das in der Bürger der gelddebatte auch
schon verfolgt dass sie in der Union zu
Recht darauf sehr allergisch reagieren
aber wenn sich den zu anziehen dann
dürfen Sie nicht sich wundern wenn sie
danach benannt werden deswegen war es
für mich sehr wichtig diesen Unterschied
deutlich zu machen wenn das dazu
beiträgt dass sie Umdenken das was sie
vorgetragen haben auch dann so in
Zukunft äußern und da an dieser Politik
an einer
Oppositionsarbeit konstruktiv ist und
die in der Krise verlässlich ist
mitwirken dann hat ja mein Wortbeitrag
und dass ich sie direkt angesprochen
habe schon etwas positiv bewirkt und da
würde ich mich sehr freuen
und jetzt hat Anja Liebert das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bundesregierung hat ja in den
vergangenen Monaten bereits eine
Vielzahl sozialpolitischer Maßnahmen und
Entlastungen auf den Weg gebracht denn
wir nehmen die Sorgen und die Nöte der
Menschen vor den steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten und natürlich auch
vor den massiv steigenden heiz- und
Wohnkosten ernst und eine bezahlbare
angemessene und sichere Wohnung zählt zu
den Grundbedürfnissen aller Menschen
und mit der geplanten Erweiterung des
Kreises der wohngeldberechtigen
Berechtigten adressieren wir ja sehr
viele verschiedene Gruppen kleine
Menschen mit kleinen Renten
geringverdienende Alleinerziehende und
größere Familien aber die wohngeldreform
ist auch ein Instrument der
Stadtentwicklungspolitik unser Ziel ist
es nämlich dass Menschen mit mittleren
und niedrigen Einkommen nicht an den
Rand gedrängt werden an den Stadtrand
oder an den Rand wo es eben bestimmte
wohnensituationen gibt sondern auch ein
Krankenpfleger oder die Servicekraft in
der Gastronomie müssen sich das wohnen
dort leisten können im Zentrum wenn Sie
mögen ohne lange Pendelwege zur Arbeit
in Kauf zu nehmen
und unser Leitbild der Stadtentwicklung
sind die lebendigen Quartiere mit einer
vielfältigen Nutzung da gehört Arbeiten
Wohnen Freizeit und Erholung unmittelbar
zusammen es muss aber auch eine Mischung
unterschiedlicher Milieus sein
unterschiedlicher Lebensstile und
unterschiedliche Einkommensgruppen und
dafür ist natürlich auch die
wohngeldreform da dass wir diese
nutzungsgemischte Stadt erhalten können
die wohngeldreform hilft aber auch den
Kommunen und insbesondere den
finanzschwachen Kommunen denn diese
werden finanziell von den Ausgaben für
die Sozialhilfe deutlich entlastet und
das schon im nächsten Jahr mit circa 200
Millionen Euro
und 380.000 Haushalte werden aus dem SGB
II Bezug also dem Bezug vom Jobcenter
und der Grundsicherung in den
Wohngeldbezug wechseln und auch das
entlastet die Kommunen deutlich und wir
müssen mittelfristig natürlich unsere
Kommunen beim Bürokratieabbau bei einem
vereinfachten Antragsverfahren und auch
mit Hilfe von Digitalisierung das wurde
ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen
deutlich unterstützen und im
Gesetzentwurf
im Gesetzentwurf sind ja auch schon
einige Maßnahmen vorgestellt wie man den
verarbeitungsaufwand in den Kommunen
reduzieren kann durch die Verlängerung
des Bewilligungszeitraums von 12 auf 18
Monate und mit sinnvollen
übergangszeiträumen von einem ins andere
System und damit können wir den Ämtern
Luft verschaffen und es wird trotzdem
eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe für die
Kommunen diese Reform umzusetzen wir
müssen daher auch an einer besseren
Finanzausstattung für die Kommunen
arbeiten und wir Grünen setzen uns
gemeinsam in der Ampel natürlich auch
für eine Lösung der
altschuldenproblematik finanzwocher
Kommunen ein denn wir brauchen
Ausstattung und Personal in den Kommunen
vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion ist der Kollege
Martin Diedenhofen das der nächste
Redner würde ich sagen ja und Martin
Dietenhofen von SPD ist der letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Ministerin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 kommt
Heizkostenzuschuss zwei wir kennen es
aus der Filmbranche ist ein Film
erfolgreich wird schneller ein zweiter
Teil nachgelegt obwohl wir erst im
Frühjahr des den ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss verabschiedet haben
reden wir heute schon über Teil 2 aber
anders als in der Filmbranche da haben
wir den zweiten Teil leider nicht weil
wir als Regierungskoalition vom Erfolg
des ersten Teils profitieren möchten wir
machen das weil es aufgrund der
aktuellen Situation ganz dringend
notwendig ist
beim zweiten Teil werden wir auch wie
bei Filmen üblich nochmal drauflegen und
planen jetzt mit 415 Euro das ist bitter
notwendig damit Wohngeld und
bafög-empfängerinnen und Empfänger eine
Chance haben über die Runde zu kommen
denn die dicke Rechnung wird spätestens
in den kalten Monaten eintrudeln und
deswegen ist für die SPD-Fraktion auch
vollkommen klar wir dürfen diese
Menschen nicht im Regen stehen lassen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das heißt auch und da wende ich mich
auch noch mal an die Unionsfraktion dass
das Geld schnell zu den Menschen kommen
muss in meiner Heimat Rheinland-Pfalz
ist das längst geschehen auch die
anderen SPD-geführten Bundesländer haben
ihre Hausaufgaben gemacht und den ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss bereits ausgezahlt
ganz im Gegensatz übrigens zu den
unionsgeführten Ländern wie
beispielsweise Bayern und da sage ich
ganz klar viel vielleicht sollte Herr
Söder nicht nur heiße Luft produzieren
sondern auch mal wirklich etwas für die
Menschen in diesen Krisenzeiten machen
bei Filmen kommt nach einem ersten und
einem zweiten Teil häufig sogar noch ein
dritter oder ein vierter Teil wir haben
aber anderes vor was das Wohngeld angeht
wir werden nämlich quasi eine Serien
nachlegen im Zuge der wohngeldreform
werden wir nicht nur den Empfängerinnen
und Empfängerkreis massiv ausweiten
sondern eine dauerhafte
heizkostenkomponente einführen und dann
wissen die Menschen auch klar womit Sie
rechnen können
sie kennen sicher diese Filme bei denen
man schon am Anfang weiß dass es ein
Happy End geben wird und auch wie das
aussehen wird in der aktuellen Krise
können wir das nicht sagen das gehört zu
Wahrheit dazu und das Blaue vom Himmel
zu versprechen das überlasse ich an der
Stelle auch lieber der Opposition was
wir aber versprechen können als Ampel
dass wir alles geben dafür die
zusätzlichen Belastungen so gut wie
möglich abzufedern und dass wir
niemanden diesem Land alleine lassen
herzlichen Dank
dann schieße ich jetzt die Aussprache
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Gesetzentwurf Würfe auf den Drucksachen
39 36 und 38 84 an die in der
Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschusses
vorgeschlagen ich sehe keine anderen
Wünsche dann ist das so beschlossen
jetzt rufe ich auf die
Tagesordnungspunkte 17a und B Beratung
der Beschlussempfehlungen des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
zu den Anträgen der Fraktion Die Linke
mit dem titelstrom und gassperren
verbieten sowie Gas und strompreisdeckel
einführen über die Beschlussempfehlung
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit
dem Titel Strom und gassperren verbieten
werden wir später namentlich abstimmen
verabredet ist es 68 Minuten zu
debattieren und ich eröffne die
Aussprache und die erste Rednerin ist
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen dr Ingrid
Nestler
jetzt also zwei Anträge der
Linksfraktion verbraucher sollen wegen
Zahlungsfähigkeit nicht mehr gesperrt
werden dürfen das ist der eine Antrag
doch zunächst den Nestle Energiepreise
sie sind bitter für viele Menschen in
diesem Land und für viele Unternehmen
und ich bin sicher dass es keinen
Abgeordneten und keine Abgeordnete in
diesem Haus gibt die das nicht wissen
mir persönlich hat das schon mehrmals
nachts den Schlaf geraubt und ich glaube
wir können die Debatte heute und hier
auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren wenn
wir das einfach erstmal festhalten wenn
wir nicht versuchen uns gegenseitig klar
zu machen wie schlimm die Situation ist
und dabei hoffen dass es so rüberkam als
hätten die anderen das nicht gemerkt wir
alle haben es gemerkt deswegen sollten
wir die Debatten Zeit heute dafür zu
nutzen darüber zu reden wie wir den
Menschen und Unternehmen am besten
helfen können
zum einen ist natürlich Unterstützung
wichtig direkte Unterstützung wir haben
mittlerweile im vierten Paket viel Geld
mobilisiert viel Kraft mobilisiert um
Menschen um Unternehmen in der Not zu
helfen um sie zu unterstützen das ist
gut so das brauchen wir
wir Grüne haben uns immer dafür
eingesetzt dass diese Gelder möglichst
zielgenau bei denjenigen ankommen
Menschen und Unternehmen die sie haben
dringendsten brauchen aber es ist auch
klar die Gelder müssen schnell und
unbürokratisch schießen und das bedeutet
eben auch dass sie nicht ganz so
zielgenau sein könnten wie wenn man sehr
sehr komplizierte prüfungssysteme
aufsetzt
wir haben also
wir haben den klaren Willen und die
Kraft bewiesen Menschen und Unternehmen
zu unterstützen das andere aber was wir
brauchen was auf der Hand liegt und was
manchmal zu kurz kommt ist wir müssen
und das ist doch die einzige Lösung die
das Problem wirklich an der Wurzel packt
wir müssen unabhängiger werden von
diesen unbezahlbar
en Schutz wir müssen unabhängiger werden
und deshalb bin ich sehr stolz auf diese
ampelregierung die es geschafft hat das
größte erneuerbaren Energien
Ausbauprogramm aller Zeiten aufzulegen
und schon wieder nachgelegt hat und
insig in der vorletzten Sitzungswoche
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass wir mit
Minister Habeck ein Minister haben der
wirklich handelt der sich nicht
wegdrückt wenn es schwierig wird der die
Beschleunigung von Genehmigung
hinbekommen hat wie keiner vor ihm und
auch ein Energiesparverordnung auf den
Tisch gelegt hat
werden sie gerne in der Zwischenfrage
dann erzähle ich Ihnen ganz viel was
Minister haben gemacht hat aber so
möchte Zeit nicht denn was wir natürlich
auch machen müssen ja wir brauchen
andere Energiequellen aber was natürlich
auch machen müssen um unabhängiger zu
werden von diesen derzeit unbezahlbaren
fossilen die deshalb sucht unbezahlbar
sind weil wir ein bisschen zu viel
verbrauchen es gibt ja keinen Grund
dafür dass Gas aus Norwegen so teuer
sein muss wie es derzeit ist außer dass
wir eben etwas mehr verbrauchen als wir
haben etwas mehr verbrauchen als wir
beziehen können was wir also auch machen
müssen ist den Verbrauch zu reduzieren
und einzusparen in der Industrie genauso
wie in den Haushalten
und da verehrt Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Linksfraktion die sie heute wieder
die Themen auf den Tisch gelegt haben da
hat mich ihr Verhalten den letzten
Wochen schon sehr verwundert ich habe
sie mehrmals persönlich darauf
hingewiesen dass unsere einsparappelle
unser Aufruf zur Solidarität weniger zu
verbrauchen von dem knappen Gut Erdgas
dass sie sich eben nicht gerade an die
Leute richten die gerade kein Geld mehr
haben es zu bezahlen sondern hat die
gesamte Gesellschaft und in erster Linie
an die reichen die am meisten Energie
verbrauchen und die sparen können
und wäre ich heute nicht die erste
Rednerin ich hätte Wetten abgeschlossen
wann der erste das Wort Waschlappen auf
dem Tisch bringt ja ein Wort das einmal
erwähnt worden ist völlig aus dem
Kontext gerissen hunderttausend Mal
100.000 mal wieder
wiederverwendet worden ist um all
diejenigen die unsere Gesellschaft
zusammenhalten und vor großer Not
bewahren wollen die unserer Gesellschaft
sagen wollen dass wir gemeinsam diesen
knappen Gut Erdgas eben seriös und
sparsam umgehen müssen um all diese zu
diskreditieren und lächerlich zu machen
ich habe sie darauf hingewiesen sie
haben es immer wieder gemacht das ist
nicht Schutz derjenigen der Menschen mit
wenig Geld genau dadurch teilen Sie das
Problem in die Höhe sie machen
diejenigen lächerlich die etwas für die
Gesellschaft tun wollen und die die
Energiepreise nach unten bringen für den
billigen politischen Punkt ja sie wollen
den politischen billigen Punkt in den
Social Media sie wollen viele Klicks und
viele Likes aber damit herrscht
verschärfen wir das Problem damit heizen
Sie das Problem an die wenn die zehn
Prozent reichsten in Deutschland einfach
nur so viel Energie verbrauchen würden
wie ein Durchschnittsbürger da den
Kollegen sind 20% eingespart
Frau Kollegin kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss sie sagen
Frau Kollegin ich habe auch was gesagt
ich habe auch recht
los
Inge kommt zu stoppen von den
bündnisgrün es geht um zwei Anträge der
Linken einmal fordern sie sperren für
Verbraucher wegen einer
Zahlungsunfähigkeit soll es nicht mehr
geben und zum anderen einen
energiepreistrikel für Strom und Gas
soll dringend her und zwar anders
ausgestaltet als der den die Kommission
zumindest beim Gas vorgeschlagen hat
Marie lena weiß jetzt für die CDU
weil der Doppel Worms offensichtlich
noch nicht so wumpst wie er soll wollen
Sie jetzt mit dem Verbot von Strom und
Gas sperren dafür sorgen dass die
Wohnzimmer im Winter warm bleiben ich
sage das ist einer der schlechtesten
Vorschläge die momentan auf dem Tisch
legen und ich will Ihnen gern darlegen
warum halten wir zunächst einmal fest
wenn wir heute über Strom und Gas
sperren diskutieren dann diskutieren wir
nicht mehr über die 290.000 Anschlüsse
die im Jahr 2019 gesperrt wurden oder
über die 230.000 Anschlüsse im Jahr 2020
wir sprechen über Millionen von Strom
und Gasanschlüssen von den
Geringverdienern bis weit in die
Mittelschicht hinein jeder dritte Bürger
in diesem Land hat jetzt genau in diesem
Moment Angst die Strom- und Gasrechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen zu können jeder
dritte Betrieb bankt um seine Existenz
diese dramatische Situation lässt sich
nicht durch ein Verbot von Gas und
Stromsparen in die Zukunft verschieben
sondern muss jetzt bei der Wurzel
gepackt werden
Sperrungen zu verbieten das mag ein paar
Monate gut gehen aber das kann doch
nicht die Lösung sein denn eines ist
klar an dem Tag an dem die Politik das
Verbot wieder aufhebt fällt das
Kartenhaus in sich zusammen
es steht doch außer Frage dass derjenige
der eine Leistung entgegengenommen hat
in diesem Fall Strom oder Gas bezogen
hat irgendwann für diese Leistung auch
bezahlen muss egal ob heute in einem
Monat oder in einem Jahr dieser Tag wird
zweifelsohne kommen und dann wird das
Ausmaß der Bugwelle die betroffenen
Bürger schlagartig in die Realität
zurückholen das war der eine Punkt
der andere ist wer soll ihren Vorschlag
den eigentlich bezahlen der Staat die
Allgemeinheit die Energieversorger ihr
Antrag Liebe linke schweigt dazu ich
kann es verstehen schließlich sind sie
ja fürs verteilen da und nicht fürs
erwirtschaften zuständig aber klar ist
doch dass diese Kosten zunächst bei den
Energieversorgung hängen bleiben allen
voran bei unseren 900 Stadtwerken in
Deutschland den 900 Stadtwerken für die
der Wirtschaftsminister nicht zuständig
ist und an die auch Sie wie Sie mit
Ihrem Antrag zeigen nicht denken durch
ihren Vorschlag Gas und Stromsperren zu
verbieten gefährden sie die
wirtschaftliche Existenz der Versorger
und Stadtwerke die in Vorleistung gehen
ihre Lieferzusage einhalten aber keine
Gegenleistung mehr bekommen
der der Versorger die für die Energie
Grundversorgung als Teil der
Daseinsvorsorge da sind und die den
Kunden ja ohnehin schon Ratenzahlungen
von mindestens sechs Monaten anbieten
müssen sie bestrafen also die Stadtwerke
die schon immer sozialgerecht agieren
die alles dafür tun die Kunden vor Ort
zu schonen und für die Gas und
Stromsperren schon immer die absolut die
ultima ratio waren vor allem aber sorgen
sie durch ihren Vorschlag dafür dass der
Allgemeinheit auf zweifache Weise
Schaden entsteht zum einen weil die
Preise wieder steigen werden denn
Ausfälle werden durch die zahlenden
Kunden kompensiert und zum anderen weil
sie den Stadtwerken die wirtschaftliche
Grundlage entziehen damit können Sie
Ihre Gewinne nicht für die Schwimmbäder
den ÖPNV oder die Transformation zur
Klimaneutralität einsetzen
Liebe linke sehen sie ein dass uns Ihr
Antrag nicht weiterhilft und helfen Sie
stattdessen mit die Regierung davon zu
überzeugen dass die beste Entlastung und
Preisbremse nicht ein Verbot von Strom
und gassperren ist die beste Entlastung
erreichen wir durch eine Erhöhung des
energieangebots
ich sage ausdrücklich danke liebe
Regierung dass Sie den Weg frei gemacht
haben beim biogastik und ich bitte sie
erhören sie das Tempo bei der Kohle
legen Sie die Scheuklappen bei
heimischer Gasförderung ab zeigen sie
sich einsichtig bei der Kernenergie und
lassen Sie alle drei aktiven
Kernkraftwerke am Netz
die Intention ihres zweiten antragsliebe
Linksfraktion ist der gut gemeint wenn
auch inhaltlich nicht umsetzbar sehen
Sie es mir deshalb an dieser Stelle nach
wenn ich mich nicht mit ihrem dürftigen
Dreizeiler auseinandersetze sondern mich
stattdessen noch einmal klar und
deutlich an sie Wände Liebe
Bundesregierung es ist
ausdruckkommission Gas externen
insbesondere wirtschaftlichen
Sachverstand ins Boot geholt haben
schade dass sie das nicht schon vor der
Sommerpause gemacht haben als absehbar
war in welcher Situation wir uns vor dem
nahenden Winter befinden
ich appelliere an Sie sorgen Sie dafür
dass unsere mittelständischen Betriebe
jetzt kurzfristig Entlastung bekommen
eine gaspreisbremse im März kommt zu
spät bei einer Verzehnfachung der Preise
am Spotmarkt können Betriebe nicht
einfach fünf Monate weiter produzieren
eine Einmalzahlung im Dezember reicht
nicht aus und drohen die
Betriebsschließungen im Winter zu
verhindern sorgen Sie dafür dass
zumindest schnelle Anpassungen am
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm und
Liquiditätshilfen für spürbare
Entlastung sorgen bis die gaspreisbremse
kommt und vor allem denken Sie daran
dass mit der gaspreisbremse erst die
Hälfte getan ist vergessen Sie nicht das
Stromproblem und kümmern Sie sich um die
Strompreise und lassen sie zu guter
Letzt auch nicht diejenigen im Regen
stehen die am Öl hängen und auf Pellets
angewiesen sind und ebenfalls hohen
Preissteigerungen ausgesetzt sind
Liebe Bundesregierung ihr Kanzler hat
gestern prophetenhaft verkündet dass er
Putins gaserpressung schon im letzten
Winter vorausgesehen habe für die
Zukunft rate ich Ihnen verkünden sie
ihre Prophezeiungen leiser und handeln
Sie stattdessen schneller und spürbarer
geben Sie unseren Bürgern und betrieben
eine Perspektive wie sie durch den
Winter kommen
was die Strom- und gassperren angeht da
gibt es ja unterschiedliche Meinungen in
der Ampel Bundesjustizminister Buschmann
hatte sich skeptisch zu einem Vorstoß
von Verbraucherschutzministerin Lemke
geäußert die einen Moratorium für Strom
und gassperren ins Gespräch gebracht
hatte Nina Scheer jetzt für die
SPD-Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist von der
Kollegin Ingrid Nestle gerade schon
dargelegt worden wir haben eine fossile
energiepreiskrise das dürfen wir bei all
dem nicht vergessen wir hätten keine
preisprobleme mit der Energie wenn wir
schon längst beschleunigt auf
erneuerbare Energien umgestiegen werden
und wir wissen dass es hier schon
vielfache diskutiert worden ich erwähnt
erneut dass da auch in der großen
Koalition leider kräftige Bremsen
installiert wurden und wir hatten alle
Mühe als SPD-Fraktion diese Bremsen
abzuwehren
wir müssen jetzt schauen dass wir
natürlich sowohl die Entlastung
hinbekommen die wir brauchen
aufgrund dieser fossilen
energiepreiskrise und diese Entlastung
sind auf dem Weg wir haben schon über 95
Milliarden an Entlastung auf den Weg
gebracht wir fangen also nicht
keineswegs bei Null an und jetzt sind
200 Milliarden über einen erneuten
Abwehrschirm verständigt die jetzt in
die Ausgestaltung müssen das ist eine
große Aufgabe die wir noch vor uns haben
da ist natürlich darum geht das gerecht
auszugestalten und genau da liegt ja
auch der Ansatz
dass man erst überhaupt nicht zu den
Strom- und Gas sperren kommt das ist der
wirksame Ansatz dies eben zu verhindern
denn wenn man dies nicht täte dann wäre
natürlich die Konsequenz dass ein
Unterbinden von Strom und gasperren nur
Schulden anhäufen würde und das mit gilt
es ja gerade zu verhindern deswegen ist
der erste wichtige Schritt deswegen ist
der erste wichtige Schritt dass man
natürlich diese Entlastungen auf den Weg
bringt um diese Schuldensituation bei
den Menschen nicht entstehen zu lassen
und natürlich dies den folgeeffekt der
dann ja auch eintrete dass die
Stadtwerke die kommunalen Stadtwerke
dass die Versorger dann das auf diesen
auf diesen nicht bezahlten Rechnungen
sitzen blieben dass die dann eben auch
nicht das an als Problem vor die Tür
bekommen deswegen ist es wichtig dass
man in dieser zweierlei in diesen
zweierlei Hinsichten diese
entlastungspakete schnell auf den Weg
bringt
als andere Koalition und auch als
SPD-Fraktion machen wir natürlich da
nicht Halt denn wir wissen es kann
trotzdem hier und da zu kritischen
Situationen kommen und deswegen haben
wir uns auch dafür ausgesprochen dass es
abwendungsvereinbarungen geben soll und
dass dafür auch das Energierecht
nachgebessert werden muss wenn man das
anders nicht hinbekommt das haben wir
uns klar ausgesprochen dass eben hier
eine klare Verankerung hin muss dass
eine
abwendungsvereinbarungen
gearbeitet wird und das bedeutet
natürlich dann auch dass wir vom Ziel
her vom Ergebnis her diese Fälle
unterbinden wollen ja es soll keine
Strom- und gasperren geben aber der Weg
dahin ist eben entscheidend damit es
nicht zu diesen von mir gerade schon
genannten Überforderungen kommt
ich möchte aber zu dem erstgenannten
Punkt noch mal zurückkommen denn es sagt
sich immer so leicht dass wir hier
mitten in einer
Preiskrise sind und dass wir schnell
umsteigen und ich möchte einmal kurz
erwähnen weil es tags aktuell
unverzichtbar ist darauf zu Rückzug zu
bekommen oder das zu erwähnen auch an
dieser Stelle auf europäischer Ebene
ist gerade ein sehr großer Kampf darum
welche Rolle die erneuerbaren Energien
wie schnell haben werden und es muss für
uns alle klar sein dass wir von diesem
Pfad der das beschleunigten Umstiegs auf
erneuerbare auch aus Preisgründen aus
bezahlbarkeitsgründen nicht abweichen
dass wir so beschleunigt wie nur irgend
geht auf erneuerbare umsteigen der
eu-wirtschaftsausschuss hat heute daran
ein Fragezeichen gesetzt und auch einige
EU-Staaten wollen das im
repower-eu-programm nun auch das 45%
erneuerbare Ziel bis 2030 aufgeweicht
wird von unserer Seite muss ganz klar
sein das ist nicht die Antwort die
Antwort lautet erneuerbare so schnell
wie möglich das sind die
kostengünstigsten Formen der
Energiegewinnung und wenn wir von diesem
Pfad abweichen dann wird auch kein
Rettungspaket der Welt mehr
Bezahlbarkeit von Energie-
Möglichkeit der Energieversorgung heißt
energiewendebeschleunigung vielen Dank
jetzt spricht Marc Bernhard für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
also nachdem was ich jetzt gerade hier
schon in dieser Debatte alles gehört
habe wo sich doch schon sagen die
Regierung hat ganz offensichtlich die
Dramatik nicht verstanden bei Frau
Nestlé sie haben ja sinngemäß im Prinzip
gesagt wenn die Menschen sich die
Energie nicht mehr leisten können dann
sollen sie halt in Zukunft weniger
verbrauchen das haben sie im Prinzip
gesagt und ich glaube ich muss schon
noch mal daran erinnern dass die
Spritpreise seit Jahresbeginn um 60
Prozent gestiegen sind sich die
Strompreise verdoppelt haben und der
graspreis sich mehr als verdreifacht hat
wenn also eine vierköpfige Familie an
Anfang des Jahres 1200 Euro fürs Gas
bezahlt hat da muss sie heute 4000 Euro
bezahlen und über die Preisexplosion bei
den Lebensmitteln haben wir noch gar
darüber gesprochen Herr Kollege sprechen
wir ich nein ich bitte dann um eine
zwischenintervention nachher aber
sprechen wir doch mal darüber warum denn
die Menschen überhaupt in dieser
Notsituation sind ja lassen Sie mich
doch erstmal meinen Gedanken entwickeln
dann können sie nachher gerne eine
Intervention machen sprechen wir doch
erstmal darüber warum denn die Menschen
überhaupt in dieser Notsituation sind
nämlich ganz einfach weil die Regierung
acht Monate lang nichts gemacht hat und
diese Katastrophe abzuwenden laut
Minister Habeck zählt doch angeblich
jede Kilowattstunde bereits am 6 April
habe ich den Bundeskanzler gefragt was
die Regierung unternommen hat um die
Laufzeitverlängerung und die wieder in
Betriebnahme der Kernkraftwerke zeitnah
zu erreichen um damit für bezahlbare
Energie zu sorgen die lapidare Antwort
von Olaf Scholz war dass die
Kernkraftwerke nicht weiterlaufen werden
am 7 Juli haben sie alle hier ausnah
Kurs im übrigen auch Sie von der Union
den afd-antrag die Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen in einer
namentlichen Abstimmung abgelehnt seit
Monaten fordern wir not nordstream 2 im
Betrieb zu nehmen zahlen Sie jetzt so
lange gewartet bis Staatsterroristen die
Pipeline gesprengt haben aber eine
Leitung ist noch funktionsfähig und
könnte sofort den Betrieb genommen
werden
zudem fordern wir seit Monaten die
Nutzung unserer eigenen Gasvorkommen die
für die nächsten 40 Jahre russisches Gas
komplett ersetzen können
außerdem die Energiesteuer zu senken die
CO2-Steuer abzuschaffen und die
Mehrwertsteuer für Energie auf Null zu
setzen aber das haben sie ja alles
abgelehnt und haben dann angefangen uns
Märchen von lndit
lng-industrieanlagen und
wasserstoffpipelines aus Afrika zu
erzählen die uns durch diesen und den
nächsten Winter bringen sollen haben sie
die Geschichten gerade eben fortgesetzt
und wie sollen jetzt diese
Märchengeschichten denn ganz konkret
jetzt dafür sorgen dass die Menschen
über den Winter kommen nachdem sie nun
acht Monate verschlafen haben fangen Sie
jetzt an
am Anfang der Heizperiode darüber
nachzudenken was man tun könnte um den
Menschen nach dem Winter vielleicht
möglicherweise helfen zu können
also dann also genau dann wenn viele
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen bereits
pleite sind und tausende von
Arbeitsplätzen vernichtet wurden nachdem
diese Regierung also total versagt hat
muss jetzt jede Möglichkeit genutzt
werden um die Menschen und die
Unternehmen über den Winter zu bringen
und deshalb fordern auch wir eine Gas-
und strompreisdeckel jedoch nur als
akute zeitlich begrenzte Notbrücke um
Gas und Strom wieder bezahlbar zu machen
die Menschen und die Unternehmen
brauchen nämlich keine
Märchengeschichten sondern jetzt hier
und sofort massive Entlastungen denn
über den Winter kommt niemand mit einem
Bums doppelwumms unterhaken und
sonstigen inhaltslehren
Durchhalteparolen
die Energieversorger übrigens wollen auf
sperren nicht verzichten beim
Energieversorger mit Gas haben dieses
Jahr bislang etwa 17.000 Gaskunden eine
Mahnung aufgrund von Zahlungsverzug
erhalten im vergangenen Jahr waren es
insgesamt nur 13.000 900 nur in
Anführungsstrichen Michaels für die FDP
Beweise kann man hier immer alles das
was der Rest des Hauses über ihre Reden
denkt unmittelbar formulieren das
entspannt einen persönlich sehr und gibt
einem großen innere Freiheit tatsächlich
entfernt es einen aber ein bisschen
davon das zu sagen was wir alles Gutes
machen und ich habe mich für heute mal
entschlossen genau darauf einzugehen
denn nicht mal die fünf Minuten werden
dafür reichen ihnen zu erklären was wir
alles schon unternommen haben und in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten doch
Unternehmen werden um dieses Land aus
der Abhängigkeit zu bringen die wir im
Energiebereich von Russland haben und es
gibt ja noch eine große Gemeinsamkeit
die eben die Mitte Fraktionen dieses
Hauses vereint nämlich das wir aus der
großen Abhängigkeit von einem Staat der
Energie als Waffe gegen uns in
Westeuropa einsetzt rausführen wollen
das wollen sie am rechten Rand ja gar
nicht sie wollen uns weiter in dieser
Abhängigkeit reinführen und der
Anschluss von Nord Stream 2 wie sie ihn
gerade gefordert haben ist der beste
Beleg dafür sie machen die Augen zu vor
einem brutalen Angriffskrieg und wollen
noch größere Abhängigkeiten von Russland
und die Tatsache dass sie jetzt hier so
rumschreien zeigt ich habe recht
und das ist eben der Unterschied zu der
sehr verantwortungsvollen Mehrheit hier
im Hause sei sie gerade in der Regierung
oder auch in der Opposition wir sorgen
für Energieunabhängigkeit von Russland
wir sorgen dafür dass wir unsere eigenen
Geschicke wieder in die eigenen Hände
nehmen können und ja mittelfristig ist
der Ausbau der Erneuerbaren der
freiheitsenergien der beste Weg um genau
das zu erreichen und jeder hätte das
eigentlich erkennen müssen jeder könnte
das erkennen dass das jetzt der richtige
Weg ist nun gab es ja auch noch den
Anwurf damit kommen wir nicht durch den
nächsten Winter nee stimmt deswegen
haben gerade die energiepolitikerinnen
und Politiker die hier ja im Raum
vertreten sind bis hierhin mehr Gesetze
verhandelt als das glaube ich jemals in
diesem Bereich in dieser Geschwindigkeit
stattgefunden hat und nein
es bringt uns nicht durch den nächsten
Winter dass wir in zwei bis fünf Jahren
noch ganz andere zubauziele in bei den
Erneuerbaren erreicht haben wollen aber
es bringt uns durch den Winter das stand
heute 95 Prozent Füllstand in den
deutschen gasspeichern vorhanden ist
etwas was die Russen im letzten Jahr
verhindert haben weil sie ein Gutteil
davon besessen haben das ist etwas wofür
wir gesorgt haben weil wir im März
dieses Jahres Gesetze gemacht haben die
uns durch den nächsten Winter bringt da
waren sie wie üblich nur mit pöbeln
beschäftigt sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren von der rechten und wir verändern
unsere importquellen und das in
Rekordgeschwindigkeit ja warum haben wir
denn neuerdings LNG Import Terminals
warum sind wir denn in den fsa-news dran
warum haben wir denn Infrastrukturausbau
in diesem Land in einer Geschwindigkeit
wie es ihnen die letzten Jahrzehnte
nicht gegeben hat weil die Ampel dafür
gesorgt hat weil wir verantwortungsvoll
für dieses Land handeln und weil wir den
Menschen eine klar Perspektive dafür
geben wie wir durch die nächsten beiden
Winter kommen damit dieses Land nicht in
die größte Rezession seiner Geschichte
Gerät sondern damit dieses Land
Zuversicht erhält und in dieser
Zuversicht an der kann jeder hier im
Haus mitarbeiten und ehrlich gesagt ich
erwarte es auch von jedem in diesem Haus
dass er daran mitarbeitet denn die
Menschen in diesem Land die
interessieren sich überhaupt nicht dafür
ob nun diese Partei oder jene Partei
gerade mal was vorgeschlagen hat die
interessieren sich dafür dass wir Ihre
Probleme lösen und dass wir dafür sorgen
dass genügend Energie in den nächsten
Monaten und vor allem in den nächsten
beiden Wintern zur Verfügung steht und
ein Thema ist da eine ganze Menge haben
wir gemacht wir bringen wieder
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz obwohl es
keiner gewollt hat in der Koalition vor
dem Angriffskrieg wir sehen was
notwendig ist ein Thema das im Moment
noch in der Diskussion ist ist wie viel
wir bei der Kernenergie tun sie wissen
wir als Freie Demokraten sprechen uns
dafür aus dass wir hier mehr Kapazitäten
ans Netz nehmen
ich habe in der Zeitung gelesen es gäbe
einen Streit darüber ich kann nur davor
warnen kann nur davor warnen jede
inhaltliche Diskussion die mit
unterschiedlichen Zielen aber in der
Sache vernünftig geführt wird als ein
solchen Streit zu deklarieren
wir Freie Demokraten
wir Freie Demokraten werben dafür dass
wir mehr Kapazität ans Netz bringen als
das aktuellste Szenario im Stresstest
beschreibt warum weil sich der
Stresstest in den letzten Wochen bereits
überholt hat und wir wollen nicht in
eine Lage kommen in der wir sagen müssen
es ist noch schlechter gekommen als wir
uns das haben vorstellen können wir
würden lieber in einer Lage sein in der
wir hinterher sagen können wir hätten es
nicht unbedingt machen müssen aber das
werden wir erst hinterher erfahren wir
sorgen mit Sicherheit Planbarkeit und
Verlässlichkeit dafür dass die Menschen
in diesem Land Hoffnung und Zuversicht
bekommen können meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Michael Kruse von der FDP voller
Hoffnung und Zuversicht anders sieht das
sicherlich am Mira Mohammed Ali die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken der
Bundestag debattiert über zwei Entwürfe
der Linken einmal fordern sie die
Sperren für Verbraucher wegen einer
Zahlungsunfähigkeit nicht mehr
zu verhängen und zum anderen eine
energiepreisdeckel für Strom und Gas der
aber anders gestaltet ist als der der
Kommission
muss sie aufbrauchen wer keine hat kommt
in größte Schwierigkeiten die Schlangen
bei den Tafeln werden immer länger immer
mehr Menschen sind betroffen die niemals
erwartet hätten in so eine Lage zu
kommen immer mehr Menschen sind
überschuldet die Zahl der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen ist im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr um 34% gestiegen in dieser
großen Krise braucht es endlich klare
und entschlossene Maßnahmen es muss
Schluss sein mit dem teuerwahnsinn
Deckeln sie Strom und Gaspreise jetzt
Kolleginnen und Kollegen außerdem ist es
zwingend notwendig die allergrößten
sozialen Härten nicht nur ein kleines
bisschen abzumildern sie müssen
ausgeschlossen werden darum muss es
sofort verboten werden dass Menschen die
in Zahlung Schwierigkeiten sind das den
Strom oder Gas in ihrer Wohnung
abgeschaltet werden darf Schluss mit
Strom und Gas sperren und keiner
behauptet dass das die alleinige Lösung
ist natürlich nicht aber es ist eben ein
wichtiger Baustein was macht die
Bundesregierung sie will eine Gaspreis
Verbraucher und für Handwerksbetriebe ab
März was ist das denn eine Preisbremse
am Ende der Heizperiode wirklich damit
die Preise über den Winter noch
ungestört die Rechnung ist unermessliche
weiter steigen können Sie schauen
einfach zu wie immer größeres Teil der
Bevölkerung für Armen Sie schauen
einfach zu das Handwerksbetriebe
reihenweise werden aufgeben müssen das
ist die Wahrheit aber das geht so nicht
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dann wollen sie den Preis Deckeln
und zwar bei zwölf Cent pro
Kilowattstunde das ist das Doppelte das
vorjahrespreises für viele ist das immer
noch viel zu viel welche Antwort haben
sie für all diese Menschen ach ja sie
übernehmen die Abschlagszahlungen für
Gaskunden für einen Monat Herr
Donnerwetter ich meine sie müssen doch
selber merken dass diese spärliche
Einmalzahlung hinten und vorne nicht
ausreicht in anderen Ländern gibt es
längst einen preisdeckel in Frankreich
zum Beispiel seit Oktober 2021 lange vor
Putins Krieg so viel dazu dass es
angeblich nicht möglich sein soll die
Preise auf Vorkriegsniveau zu bringen
Herr Habeck doch das geht und genau das
brauchen wir auch hier
ihre Preisbremse ist zu spät und zu
schlecht und wo ist eigentlich der
preisdeckel für Heizöl wo ist der
preisdeckel für Strom haben sie doch
angekündigt wo ist er denn wissen sie
bevor ich im Bundestag gekommen bin war
ich zehn Jahre lang als Juristin in der
freien Wirtschaft angestellt und ich
kann Ihnen sagen für so schlechte Arbeit
wird man überall sonst entlassen und
zwar zu Recht vor der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen noch große Töne spucken
und
einen Tag dieser Luftnummer um die Ecke
von wegen doppelbums ihr Doppelpunkt ist
eine rohrkrippierer das grenzt an Villa
Täuschung das ist die Wahrheit und auch
das geht so nicht und dass sie immer
noch nicht verstanden haben wie ernst
die Lage hat man auch in den Reden hier
vorgehört das merkt man eben daran dass
sie es immer noch zulassen das
Verbrauchern zu Hause den finanziellen
Schwierigkeiten sind das den Strom und
Gas in der Wohnung abgeschaltet werden
darf sie kennen die Zahlen bisher wo
traf das eine Million Menschen oder eine
Haushalte beim Strom pro Jahr 270.000
beim Gas in diesem Jahr so melden viele
Stadtwerke wird die Zahl wird von
Zahlungsausfällen von bis zu 15%
gerechnet 15 Prozent Millionen Haushalte
werden betroffen sein in Millionen
Wohnungen droht es bald sehr kalt und
sehr dunkel zu werden wenn sie nicht
jetzt handeln es gibt nur einen Weg
stimmen Sie unserem Antrag zu verbieten
sie Strom und Gas sperren
und natürlich braucht es parallel dazu
einen Schutz schon für die Stadtwerke
ist doch keine Frage habe ich was hält
Sie davon abspannen Sie diesen
Schutzschirm doch endlich auf ja wir
brauchen diese Sofortmaßnahmen um die
Härten abzumildern die jetzt bestehen
aber das nämlich das zum Schluss sagen
es müssen auch die richtigen Lehren aus
dieser Krise gezogen werden die
Energieversorgung darf nicht länger den
Kräften des freien Marktes ausgeliefert
bleiben wir sehen doch wo das hinführt
Energieversorgung ist Daseinsvorsorge
sie wird in öffentlicher Hand danke
schön
Amira [ __ ] mit Ali hat hier noch einmal
begründet warum die Linksfraktion diese
beiden Anträge stellt allerdings sind
sie im Ausschuss schon abgelehnt worden
nachher wird namentlich abgestimmt über
den ersten Antrag sperren für
Verbraucher wegen einer
Zahlungsunfähigkeit nicht mehr
zuzulassen Bernhard Hermann jetzt für
die bundeskönig uns als Gesellschaft
mehr noch als sonst zum starken
Zusammenhalt und auch wir hier im Haus
sind dabei ein besonderer Verantwortung
hohe Energiepreise sind eine gewaltige
Herausforderung Unternehmen sehen sich
existenziell bedroht BürgerInnen wissen
oft nicht wie sie die hohen Zahlungen
stemmen sollen und wenn wir da nicht
gegensteuern würden dann drohte darüber
auch der Gesellschaft hier Zusammenhalt
in Europa zu zerbrechen genau das aber
will Putin und ich habe den Eindruck
auch manche hier im Haus
bereits vor dem russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine begann die Verknappung
russischen gases
der Angriff auf unsere Energieversorgung
begann dann nämlich bereits schon die
externe gasmangelage ist die Ursache für
hohe Preise und ja Frau weiß sie gerade
gucken gerade weg Frau weiß es war
erkennen beim letzten Winter ich war
nämlich bei Stadtwerken schon gewesen
die im letzten Winter schon das
Beklagten auf wenn Frau Merkel sagte
alles in Ordnung Putin liefert
ordentlich die Gasspeicher waren leer
man konnte und musste es sehen und
frühzeitig handeln
aber wir werden uns da Herausforderung
als Gesellschaft geschlossen stellen wir
werden die Spaltung nicht zulassen aber
nochmal wir die wir Verantwortung tragen
in Bund Ländern und Kommunen haben
gemeinsam die Herausforderung
konstruktiv anzupacken dabei ist
entschlossen das schnelles aber auch
kluges abgewogenes Handeln gefragt die
ampelkollektion tut ihren Teil um
schnell und zugleich wirksam zu helfen
und Lösung zum Preissenkung
voranzubringen mit der Strom- und
gaspressbremse schützt der
bundbürgerinnen und Unternehmen vor den
hohen Energiepreisen das vor allem ist
Grundlage dass es gar nicht erst zur
Außenstände und Energiesparen kommen
muss und die Bundesregierung hat auch
beschlossen den Schutz vor Strom und
gassperren zu erhöhen
aber nicht simple einfache Lösung ein
Instrument und alles ist gut das wird
nicht funktionieren insgesamt brauchen
wir die Perspektive direkt Betroffener
von verschiedenen Akteuren hier ist
mehrfach angesprochen worden an der
scharnierstelle zwischen BürgerInnen
Wirtschaft und Kommunen stehen an aller
Regel und das gerade auch in
Ostdeutschland regionale kommunale
Energieunternehmen der Austausch mit
ihnen war und ist mir insbesondere
wichtig auch deren Belange fließenden
unseren Entscheidungen direkt ein und
ich bin froh dass die
ministerpräsident:innen letzte Woche mit
dem Bundeskanzler ihre besondere
Bedeutung betont und festgehalten haben
dass insbesondere Stadtwerken bei Bedarf
zusätzliche Unterstützung zukommen soll
über die energiepreisbremsen hinaus
das ist richtig denn die Unterstützung
wird der besonderen vernetzenden und
damit stabilisierenden Rolle dieser
zumeist öffentlichen Akteure gerecht
letzten Endes das gehört unbedingt zur
Wahrheit sind und bleiben die
Möglichkeiten für finanzielle Entlastung
durch den Bund und auch die Länder
begrenzt darum müssen alle Haushalte
gewerbehandel Industrie überall
womöglich sich mit der Energie
nachhaltiger aufstellen klug
Energieeinsparen gehört dazu effizient
Energie nutzen und eigene Potenziale zu
Erzeugung mit Solarenergie auch mit dem
bürgerwindrat mit dem Unternehmen Rat zu
nutzen immer mehr tun das auch und das
ist gut so dass das Gehen Vertretern der
Konzernen Energiekonzerne nicht gefällt
ist mir schon klar die Zukunft gehört in
Erneuerbaren wir sehen schon heute wie
stark diese bei uns den Strompreis
senken haben wir viel erneuerbare
Energien aus Sonne und Wind im Netz
liegt der Großhandelspreise in
Deutschland schon jetzt immer öfter
deutlich unter den Preisen unser
Nachbarn ja wir haben viel angeschoben
wie investle gesagt hat
und das Schöne ist nämlich und das
gefällt Konzernvertreter natürlich nicht
das schöne an sonn- und Windenergie ist
doch dass sie alle und fast überall
nutzen können so alle an der
Energiewende auch teilhaben können
kurz gesagt wenn wir das Angebot erhöhen
mit immer mehr erneuerbaren und
gleichzeitig den Verbrauch senken
bekommen wir die Energiepreise wieder in
den Griff bis dahin müssen wir
diejenigen unter uns entlasten die es
wirklich dringend brauchen so sieht
Solidarität aus ja und bei geringerer
Nachfrage sinken auch die Preise gerade
für die die es wirklich
dringend nötig haben und die nicht
selber mehr sparen können und deswegen
ist das ab der Appell so wichtig
deswegen sind die Aufrufe zum Einsparen
so immens wichtig wenn wir als
Gesellschaft zusammenhalten werden wir
unsere weist sich echte Nachhaltigkeit
die Energiekrise meistern und
langfristig sogar gestärkt daraus
hervorgehen vielen Dank
an den König hat jetzt das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen genau vor einem
Jahr auf den Tag genau veröffentlichte
die Europäische Kommission einen
Werkzeugkasten für die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten das Ziel schnell
Maßnahmen für die steigenden
Energiepreise zu ergreifen die
Kommission schlug zum Beispiel vor den
Steuersatz auf Strom Gas Kohle und feste
Brennstoffe zu ermäßigen und gezielte
Maßnahmen zur Unterstützung für
energieintensive Betriebe zu ergreifen
der Bedarf für solche
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen war ja bereits
vor einem Jahr für jeden zu erkennen der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
hat die Probleme dann noch mal drastisch
weiter verschärft und wir können also
festhalten bereits beim
Regierungsantritt Lagen der Ampel also
solide Bausteine für ein
Unterstützungsprogramm vor ganz frei
Haus und ohne Einsetzung einer
aufwendigen Expertenkommission und was
und was hat sie damit gemacht
ganz lange erstmal gar nichts die Frage
lautet doch warum hat diese Regierung so
viel Zeit gebraucht um Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die Menschen erkennen hier
aber inzwischen schon ein System zögern
Zaudern abwarten sind längst zur
Arbeitsmethode dieser Regierung geworden
und das setzt sich bei ihrem doppelwumms
fort es spricht ja schon für sich wenn
der Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland seine Politik nur noch in
der comicsprache ausdrücken kann
aber nicht nur Ihre Sprache nicht nur
ihre Sprache sondern auch ihre Inhalte
haben etwas unseriöses denn treffender
müsste man nicht von Doppel Wumms
sondern von doppel-wirversprechen
erstens wann und wie genau soll denn nun
die gaspreisbremse kommen trotz großer
Ankündigung ist immer noch völlig unklar
welche Handlungsempfehlung der
Expertenkommission die Ampel überhaupt
am Ende umsetzen wird und zweitens weder
der Bund noch die Länder wissen wie all
das finanziert werden soll es gibt weder
eine Einigung bei dem dritten
Entlastungspaket noch bei den
versprochenen 200 Milliarden statt
Antworten stehen bei ihnen immer mehr
Fragen im Raum
unser Popo langes Warten die
Bundesnetzagentur hat bereits im Juni
die Alarmstufe des Notfallplans Gas
ausgerufen als Reaktion darauf hat sich
die Ampel dann für zwei Monate in die
Sommerpause verabschiedet offenbar
hielten sie die Krise nicht für ernst
genug um eine Sondersitzung des
Bundestages einzuberufen wir hätten im
Sommer bereits wichtige Weichen für den
kommenden Winter stellen können wie
beispielsweise die rechtzeitige
Einführung einer gaspreisbremse dann
würde diese jetzt schon greifen
die ampelregierung scheint scheint sich
über Monate hinweg in einer Parallelwelt
aufgehalten zu haben die jedenfalls
nichts mit der Lebenswirklichkeit der
Menschen in unserem Land zu tun hat ihre
Antwort
ihre Antwort auf steigende Gaspreise war
monatelang eine zusätzliche Umlage die
das Gas noch teurer machen sollte und
ihre Antwort auf eine gasknappheit bei
der Wärmeerzeugung ist nach wie vor ab
Januar noch mehr Gas zu verstrom um
damit drei Kernkraftwerke zu ersetzen
mit Vernunft und Planungssicherheit hat
das alles längst nichts mehr zu tun sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich sage es
Ihnen ganz ehrlich dass wir bei der
ampelregierung in der schwersten Krise
unserer Nachkriegsgeschichte das haben
die Menschen in diesem Land nicht
verdient im Interesse
im Interesse von Verbrauchern und
Unternehmen müssen wir jetzt die
Preissteigerungen Bremsen aus unserer
Sicht geht das nur mit einer Erweiterung
der energieangebotsseite gleichzeitig
wollen wir für wirksam Entlastung sorgen
und trotzdem auch Sparanreize erhalten
wir wollen einen gaspreisdeckel setzen
der die Grundversorgung mit Gas wieder
bezahlbar macht um gleichzeitig
Energieeinsparung weiter anzureizen soll
dieser auf einen Grundbedarf pro
Haushalt und Person festgelegt werden im
Übrigen findet sich dieser Vorschlag
auch in dem Werkzeugkasten der
EU-Kommission wir erinnern uns der der
Ampel seit einem Jahr vorliegt der
gaspreisdeckel muss jetzt kommen und
nicht das in sechs Monaten wenn die
Heizperiode langsam endet viele Menschen
werden einfach gar nicht so lange
durchhalten können bis diese Regierung
versucht zu Ostern endlich den
Weihnachtsmann zu spielen ihre Politik
baut letztlich vor allem auf dem Prinzip
Hoffnung auf ihre Pflicht wäre es seit
Monaten gewesen zumindest eine
verlässliche faktengrundlage für ihre
Politik zu schaffen und transparent zu
machen
genau das ist auch ihre Pflicht
gegenüber dem Parlament und das fängt
auch schon bei der zentralen Frage an
wie viel Gas uns denn überhaupt zur
Verfügung steht zwar haben wir in den
letzten Wochen aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium ständig
selbstbejubelungen über die Befüllung
der Gasspeicher gehört aber tatsächlich
können sie doch nicht einmal annähernd
angeben wie viel Gas im Winter vorhanden
sein wird denn selbst das in Deutschland
eingespeicherte Gas steht ja in Wahrheit
gar nicht exklusiv für den Verbrauch in
unserem Land zur Verfügung aber ein paar
Sätze möchte ich auch zum Antrag der
Linken sagen der Vorschlag der Union für
den gaspreisdeckel ist das Gegenteil der
von der Linksfraktion vorgeschlagenen
Flatrate ihre Lösung verzichtet auf
jegliche Sparanreize und würde dafür
sorgen dass auch Gas zum Fenster raus
verheizt wird unbestritten ist dass auf
die Mieter hoheitskostenzahlungen
zukommen werden im Gegensatz zu den
linken fordern wir daher eine befristete
Aussetzung der Strom- und gassperren für
den Winter ein generelles Verbot wie
sich das die Linken ausgedacht haben
würde hingegen zu neuen
Ungerechtigkeiten führen als Fazit als
Fazit können wir festhalten es ist gut
dass auch die ampelmehrheit sich
inzwischen Richtung gasbremse bewegt
aber bitte handeln Sie auch hier dieses
Mal zügiger und vor allen Dingen
unbürokratischer vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege Helmut Leban spricht jetzt
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast alle
Debatten des heutigen Tages stehen
natürlich unter dem Fokus der steigenden
Preise insbesondere der Energiepreise
das ist nicht erstaunlich und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben es verdient
dass wir uns mit der geboten
Ernsthaftigkeit auseinandersetzen und so
auch mit diesen beiden Anträgen ich will
aber zuvor zwei Vorbemerkungen machen
die eine geht an Bernhard von der AFD
ich hoffe er hat ein Kruse sehr gut
zugehört der da zwar gesagt er reagiert
nicht drauf hat aber dann
dankenswerterweise doch darauf reagiert
indem er die lange Latte der Maßnahmen
aufgezählt hat ich komme gleich auch
noch mal drauf zurück aber wir haben in
diesen acht Monaten hart gearbeitet das
Ministerium die Ministerien haben hart
gearbeitet die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter haben hart gearbeitet und
wir haben drei Pakete auf den Weg
gemacht mit 95 Millionen das ist eine
riesen Nummer Herr Bernhard
zweite Vorbemerkung die steigenden
Preise sorgen natürlich für
Verunsicherung auch davon war immer
wieder die Rede insbesondere auch bei
der Debatte um das Bürgergeld und ich
glaube wir haben alle die Verpflichtung
für möglichst viel Sicherheit zu sorgen
der Gesellschaft den Menschen den
Familien den Unternehmen Sicherheit zu
geben und in dem Zusammenhang kann ich
es überhaupt nicht verstehen wie auf
ihrer Seite auf der rechten Seite bei
AFD und auch bei der Union ein solcher
Widerstand gegen das Zurückdrängen von
Sanktionen beim Bürgergeld entstehen
kann das ist ein Stück Sicherheit die
wir den Menschen geben indem wir in die
Angst vor Sanktionen nehmen wollen diese
Sicherheit brauchen wir meine Damen und
Herren
wir lassen die Menschen in der Krise
nicht allein das ist ja auch der
Grundgedanke bei den beiden Anträgen der
Linken das ist ja zu erkennen aus
unserer Sicht haben Sie mindestens mal
drei Schwächen mit an Bord und die will
ich kurz aufführen das erste ist schon
ein bisschen erwähnt worden es ist
keinerlei Prävention das heißt es geht
darum zu erreichen dass die Menschen gar
nicht erst in eine Situation kommen wo
ihnen möglicherweise Strom und Gas
sperren drohen wir müssen sie finanziell
so in die Lage versetzen dass das
möglich ist und genau das machen wir das
heißt unser Ansatz ist die Prävention
und nicht das nachbessern
zweiter Punkt
natürlich braucht es auch die Aktivität
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir werden
das haben wir auch mehrfach hier gehört
gar nicht in der Lage sein alle
Anforderungen abzufedern wir dürfen das
Signal nicht vermitteln alles geht
weiter wie bisher es braucht die
Eigenaktivität der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und sie suggerieren mit ihren
beiden Anträgen macht so weiter wir
Deckeln das ab wir machen die Bremse
dann ist alles schick und mehr müssen
wir nicht tun das ist das falsche Signal
weil dritter Punkt wir brauchen
natürlich unbedingt die
einsparbemühungen und die brauchen wir
überall meine Damen und Herren wir
brauchen sie in der Industrie wir
brauchen sie in den Haushalten wir
brauchen sie in den Familien wir
brauchen sie im Handel beim Gewerbe wir
brauchen sie schlichtweg überall wo es
sozialverträglich möglich ist und dieses
Signal fehlt bei ihren Anträgen ganz
eindeutig deswegen ist unser Ansatz der
Ansatz der Ampel ist der richtige
gezielt zu helfen ich verweise auf das
Thema wohngeldreform haben wir gerade
diskutierter was auch immer wieder Thema
das kommt zum Heizkostenzuschuss 1 dazu
es ist sozusagen der Heizkostenzuschuss
2 das wurde hier auch schon erläutert
aus meiner Sicht genau der richtige
Schritt und vor allen Dingen wie
erweitern den Kreis der
Bezugsberechtigten das ist eine wichtige
Botschaft ins Land wenn immer Wohngeld
von Wohngeld die Rede sagen mir
natürlich auch die Menschen ich habe
wohl Wohngeld beantragt kriegs aber
leider nicht ich sage das wird sich ab
dem 1.1 kommenden Jahres ändern viel
mehr Menschen werden wohngeldberechtigt
sein lassen Sie uns Mut machen diese
Mittel auch zu beantragen es ist kein
Almosen es ist das gute Recht und das
hilft bei der Energiefrage
zusätzlich noch der Abwehrschirm
es ist unstreitig dass wir mit den Gas
und den Strompreisen umgehen umgehen
müssen und deswegen ist beides innerhalb
des abwehrschirms auch verabredet aber
auch hier kommt es auf die Details an
die Vorschläge der Expertenkommission
sind meines Erachtens komplett
zielführend weil sie nämlich verbinden
den einsparanreiz mit der Sicherheit für
die Haushalte in einem erträglichen Maß
über den Winter zu kommen die Dinge
bezahlbar zu halten und da ist es klar
aus meiner Sicht ist es klar dass wir
nicht auf das Preisniveau von vor der
Krise zurückkommen können nicht auf das
Preisniveau bevor Putin den Gashahn
abgedreht hat denn das ist ja letztlich
der Grund und von daher sind die Ansätze
vollkommen richtig und sie ersetzen das
was sie mit ihrem Ansatz hier Liebe
Linkspartei machen wollen wir sind auf
dem richtigen Weg
letzte Bekräftigung und letzter Satz die
Erneuerbaren sind die Lösung für
preiswerte bezahlbare und sichere
Energien zusammen mit
Speicherkapazitäten und genau das werden
wir tun dankeschön
Herr mit klebbank von der SPD hat das
ganze noch mal erklärt sozusagen ist
übrigens der Vorsitzende im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung der nächste Redner kommt von
der AFD Karsten Hilse
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute wie immer wenn
Kommunisten ein von ihnen
mitgeschaffenes Problem auf keinen Fall
lösen sondern nur seine Ursachen
verschleiern wollen dann verlangen sie
seine unmittelbaren Folgen zu verbieten
das kostet Sie nichts aber Sie können
sich als eine Art Robin Hood aufspielen
den Reichen nehmen und den Armen geben
das Betreiben sie dann so lange
jedenfalls wenn man sie lässt bis die
Substanz aufgebraucht oder der Kredit
verzockt ist so war es bei den auf
mikroni wo gehaltenen Miete DDR die
nicht mal die nackten
Instandhaltungskosten deckten und so ist
es jetzt wieder wenn sie verlangen Strom
und gasperren zu verbieten immer und
darauf ist Verlass wie auf das Amen in
der Kirche verlangen sie selbst mit
verschuldete Probleme zu Lasten Dritter
zu lösen besonders dann wenn es gegen
die verhassten Vermieter und andere
Kapitalisten geht dann besonders eifrig
auch wir wollen billige Strom- und
Gaspreise die jeder sich leisten aber
wenn der Dieb schreit haltet den Dieb so
wie sie jetzt dann ist es höchste Zeit
mal wieder ein Blick in die jüngste
Vergangenheit zu werfen angesponnen
angesprochen von den Grünen
kommunistischen Ideologie haben
insbesondere sie die Rechtsnachfolger
der kommunistischen SED immer wieder
nicht nur gefordert sondern auch immer
begeistert zugestimmt wenn es darum ging
das Energieangebot drastisch zu
verknappen und zu verteuern
Subventionierung der sogenannten
Erneuerbaren deutscher Alleingang beim
Atomausstieg die wohlstandsv
vernichtenden Pariser klimabeschlüsse
die unter anderem zum Kohleausstieg
führten all diese von ihnen bejubelten
Entscheidungen Fritten zwangsläufig zu
der jetzigen Preisexplosion sie sind
also sie sind also schuldig im Sinne der
Anklage die sie hier Vorbringen sie sind
schuldig mit all Ihnen hier die die
dümmste Energiepolitik der Welt
ausgeheckt oder mitgetragen haben und
nun wollen sie nicht etwa die Ursachen
der Preisexplosion bekämpfen nein sie
wollen wie immer nur deren Konsequenzen
jemand anderem Behörden jeder normal
denkt eine Mensch zu denen sie leider
nicht gehören weiß allein die bewusst
betriebene und von langer Hand geplante
und jetzt eingetretene
Energieverknappung ist das Problem wenn
sie nicht mit allen hier schon länger
herumsitzen diese irrwitzige realitäts
und Fakten Ferne
industriezerstörungspolitik Betrieben
hätten bräuchte es jetzt weder gasdeckel
noch die das Verbot von Sperren
stattdessen müssen wir das Angebot
schnellstens erhöhen durch Verlängerung
der Laufzeit der Kernkraftwerke wieder
in Betriebnahme der bereits
stillgelegten durch Förderung der
riesigen Schiefergasvorkommen unseres
Landes der Reaktivierung der
Braunkohlekraftwerke sowie Öffnung der
noch intakten nordstreams zwei Pipeline
sowie es Präsident Putin gestern
nochmals angeboten hat handeln sie
endlich im Interesse des deutschen
Volkes sonst werden sie alle irgendwo
unter irgendwann das wohlverdiente
Schicksal der FDP teilen und zugunsten
der Alternative für Deutschland
abgewählt werden vielen
[Applaus]
Olaf in der Big hat das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion
Olaf in der Weg ist der klimapolitische
Sprecher der Sozialdemokraten
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja das mit dem Fluch und Segen zugleich
was gerade Kruse sagte ist bemerkenswert
aber sagen wir da nicht zu und täglich
grüßt uns wieder das Murmeltier schon
wieder öffnen Sie die Konserve
und dürfen wir uns hier im Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestages mit ihren
Halbjahren und wenig kreativen Antrag
zur Strom- und gassperren
auseinandersetzen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Linksfraktion in der Tat
sorgen sich viele viele Menschen wegen
der hohen Strom- und Gaspreise beim
Gegensatz zu ihnen nehmen wir die Sorgen
ernst und machen uns nicht mit solaren
Ideen wie Sie ein schlanken Fuß das
System das System einfache Lösung für
komplexe Probleme hat noch nie
funktioniert und es wird auch hier nicht
funktionieren lassen Sie uns doch mal
über den Kern des Problems reden die
Preise im Stromsektor steigen vor allem
weil das Angebot stark zurückgegangen
ist dass sie als Linksfraktion vom
Marktwirtschaft Organismen wenig
verstehen wundert mich nicht aber jedem
sollte klar sein dass bei sinkendem
Angebot aber nicht ähnlich sinkender
Nachfrage der Preis steigt doch statt
wie sie an den Symptomen herumzudocktern
müssen wir den Kern das Problems angehen
und da ist die Lösung vor allem
angebotausweiten und zwar so schnell wie
es geht
wir brauchen
wir brauchen jetzt so viel Energie wie
möglich und auch wirklich die Preise zu
senken welche Ideen haben sie dazu in
den Anträgen keinen einzigen was sie
wollen ist der Umgang mit
Mangelwirtschaft statt diese im Kern zu
bekämpfen aber sei es drum das liegt
wohl eher in der Tradition ihrer Partei
damit Mangelwirtschaft da haben sie
Erfahrungen den Menschen in Deutschland
ist dabei früher wie heute nicht
geholfen deswegen ist die Antrag auch
reinster Populismus denn wer versucht
Krise mit einfachen und primitiven
Lösungen zu begegnen der streut den
Menschen Sand in die Augen wenn wir die
Knappheit und damit die Steigerung der
Preise wirklich in den Begriff bekommen
wollen dann brauchen wir neben einer
steigenden Angebot weitere Instrumente
und die kommen mir es ist doch absoluter
Blödsinn dass wir die Menschen
Unternehmen alleine lassen würden wir
haben insgesamt
Liebe Kollege Kleber gerade schon betont
hat insgesamt 100 Milliarden Euro auf
den Weg gebracht damit ist der Mensch
und Unternehmen ganz konkret geholfen
und dabei bleibt es ja nicht denn jetzt
werden 200 Milliarden Euro zusätzlich
zur Verfügung gestellt wie als
Abwehrschirm die deutsche Wirtschaft und
die Verbraucher entlasten werden und wir
verteilen das Geld nicht mit der
Gießkanne sondern wir schaffen gezielte
Entlastung im Gegensatz zu Ihnen legen
wir Wert darauf dass dieses Geld
sinnvoll eingesetzt wird und eine
nachhaltige gaspreisbremse kommen wird
das geschieht durch die
gaspreiskommission in der ausgewiesene
Experten setzen natürlich kann man auch
wie sie kurz vor Feierabend ein Antrag
aus der Schublade holen den man ja
sowieso jede Wahlperiode bringt wir
hingegen handeln da eher
verantwortungsvoll ja liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir befinden uns nicht nur
in einer der schwersten Krisen in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik nein es
ist energiekrieg den Russland gegen die
freie Welt führt und deswegen
und deswegen werden wir es durch den
Winter schaffen ohne das Unternehmen
ihren Betrieb einstellen müssen oder
Menschen zu Hause keinen Strom oder Gas
mehr haben dafür stehen die
Regierungsfraktionen in diesem Haus und
darauf können sich auch die Menschen in
unserem Land verlassen vielen Dank
war das meine Damen und Herren von der
SPD ich habe mal nachgeschaut aber in
der Tat ist er zwar norddeutscher aber
er kommt aus Luckenwalde ist dort
zumindest geboren in Brandenburg ich
hätte den Namen wahrscheinlich noch
nördlicher angesiedelt denkt sehr
ungewöhnlich der nächste Redner liebe
Bürgerinnen ist jetzt bendberg von der
SPD sie haben die ganze Zeit davon
gesprochen dass die Daseinsvorsorge im
Mittelpunkt stehen muss das tut das PCK
ist übereignet worden reden ist gekauft
worden die lng-ports werden gebaut Gas
wurde direkt gekauft das ist
Daseinsvorsorge und von der rechten
Seite kam nur der Start hätte nichts
gemacht wir sind handlungsfähig geworden
wir hatten vorher keinen Überblick
darüber was überhaupt an Gas und
Strommarkt los war heute ist der
Gaspreis am Spotmarkt wieder unter 100
Euro gefallen das ist ein Erfolg dieser
Bundesregierung ein Erfolg der
erfolgreichen Einkaufspolitik und das
bringt uns für diesen Winter auf die
richtige Spur
und natürlich soll niemand Sorge haben
dass es in der Wohnung kalt wird oder
man im Dunkeln sitzt auch dann nicht
wenn man mit der Strom- und Gasrechnung
nicht hinterher kommt der Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat gesagt niemand wird
zurückgelassen und schon gar nicht in
der größten Krise seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg meine Damen und Herren deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir Schutzplatten an
verschiedenen Stellen aufbauen die erste
Schutzplanke ist wir bauen die
erneuerbaren Energien massiv aus Strom
aus Wind Strom aus Sonne Gas aus
Biomasse Schranken die den Ausbau stören
bauen wir ab zwar nach und nach aber mit
allerhöchster Geschwindigkeit alles was
an grüner Energie ins Netz kann muss ins
Netz und das Netz muss vor allem
erweitert werden darum beschleunigen wir
den Ausbau niebkanten Ausmaß und diese
Ausbau und diese Beschleunigung das ist
soziale Politik das verstehen sie nicht
aber ich erkläre gern warum zum einen
Bremsen wir den Klimawandel was unseren
Kindern und Kindeskindern zugute kommt
damit Fluten und Brände im Sommer nicht
der Standard werden und zum anderen
schaffen wir wer Impfung und
Arbeitsplätze hier in Deutschland von 19
von 2019 bis 21 hat sich die Zahl der
Beschäftigten im Bereich der
Erneuerbaren um 30.000 erhöht und das
obwohl die Windenergie leidet und
Stellenabbau ist aber gerade diese
Diskrepanz zeigt was dafür eine Dynamik
im Markt ist und mit konkreten
Ausschreibungskriterien für die offshore
Windkraft werden wir die Wertschöpfung
in Deutschland weiter stärken ganz
konkret für den fachkräftemachwuchs weil
wir das da reingeschrieben haben das ist
ein Gesetz meine Damen und Herren das
brauchen die um an den Ausschreibungen
teilzunehmen und das schafft gut
bezahlte Arbeit hier bei uns direkt vor
Ort
und ein weiterer Vorteil der
Erneuerbaren durch den Ausbau senken wir
den Strom und Gaspreis denn mehr
windsonne Biogas im System desto weniger
Erdgas brauchen wir das heißt günstige
Preise für alle die zweite Schutzplanke
ist jetzt wo es harte Fahrt kommt
spannen wir natürlich eine Schutzschirm
auf der kurzfristig trotz aller
Unterstützung nicht in der Lage ist die
Rechnung für Strom und Heizung zu zahlen
soll sich nicht sorgen unser Ziel ist
niemand soll seine Wohnung verlieren
oder eine Gas- und Stromsperre fürchten
müssen weil es in der aktuellen
Situation etwas engen wird und wir
werden hier die Anpassung vornehmen
eins ist für uns dabei immer klar der
Schutz der Mieterin muss immer
einhergehen mit einem ausreichender
Schutz von Vermietern von
Genossenschaften und Stadtwerken denn
die meisten Vermieter sind die kleinen
die ihre Wohnung als Altersvorsorge
vermieten und die Stadtwerke können am
allerwenigsten dafür die dritte
Schutzplanke ist damit es gar nicht dazu
kommt erst das Strom und Gasrechnung
nicht gezahlt werden können müssen wir
die preisbremsen auf den Weg bringen es
ist gut dass die Ampel die nötigen
Mittel für eine gaspreisbremse frei
gemacht hat damit schaffen wir die
Sicherheit für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und auch für die Unternehmen denn
besonders geringe und mittelverdiener
treffen die hohen Preise hart und eine
Umfrage der Hans-Böckler-Stiftung hat
gezeigt dass bereits die Hälfte der
Erwerbstätigen mit einem
Haushaltseinkommen von unter 2000 Euro
netto jetzt schon genötigt sind weniger
Lebensmittel einzukaufen hungern
umzuheizen darf es in einem Bereichen
Land wie Deutschland nicht geben meine
Damen und Herren
die Preisgrenzen für Strom und Gas
bedeuten auch in durchatmen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von denen sich
viele Fragen wie soll ich die hohen
Kosten stemmen wir haben das gerade im
Tagespunkt vorher gehabt wir verdoppeln
das Wohngeld und steigern die Zahl der
Berechtigten von 600.000 auf 2 Millionen
das ist ein riesengroßer Schritt aber
der gesenkte Gaspreis hilft auch den
Unternehmen denn das bedeutet
Planungssicherheit und eine Perspektive
für die Arbeitnehmerin und Arbeitnehmer
das ist wichtig für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
den Erhalt unseres Wirtschaftsstandortes
und damit tausende Arbeitsplätze denn
gerade die kleineren haben
Direktverträge und finden kaum noch neue
Lieferanten für Strom und Gas und das
trifft konkret die Mittelständler
besonders in Schleswig-Holstein zum
Beispiel denn dort arbeiten 94 von 100
Leuten in den kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen
das und die ganze Wirtschaft kommt
übrigens in ihrem Antrag gar nicht vor
wir müssen sogar noch viel mehr tun um
unsere Wirtschaft zu unterstützen denn
diese Wirtschaft bezahlt das Essen und
Trinken der Menschen die in den
Wohnungen leben die sie jetzt schützen
wollen
und das wissen wir und darum ist die
gaspreisbremse ein erstes Kernelement
nicht das letzte die
expertenexpertenkommission hat Anfang
der Woche gute Vorschläge gemacht aber
es ist ein Zwischenbericht nicht die
Forderung der Bundesregierung dieses
Jahr aufgestellt haben und wir entwerfen
jetzt im parlamentarischen Prozess die
Lösung dazu meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland ist ein starker Sozialstaat
in dem diskutiert und gerungen wird es
wird aber nicht immer gleich gestritten
und es kommt im Endeffekt ein
Schutzschirm heraus der die
Transformation unserer Wirtschaft
schützt und die Folgen dieses
Wirtschaftskrieges lindert der gegen uns
geführt wird wir finden die Lösung
natürlich im Kampf oder per Befehl wie
in anderen Ländern sondern im Dialog das
passt nicht allen aber es ist die beste
aller Lösung und darauf können wir
wirklich stolz sein
[Applaus]
von der SPD er ist im vergangenen Jahr
in den Bundestag eingezogen hat den
gustav-wahlkreis Segeberg stormarn-mitte
gewonnen gegen den amtierenden
der von der CDU seit 2002 diesen
Wahlkreis Inhalte Ottilie klein jetzt
für die cdu/csu
stellen die Menschen in diesen Tagen
ihre Heizung an die meisten tun es mit
Unbehagen vielen offenen Fragen und
Unsicherheiten deshalb ist es richtig
dass der vorliegende Antrag den Blick
auch auf die soziale Dimension der Krise
lang denn die warme Wohnung droht auch
immer mehr zur sozialen Frage zu werden
eins ist aber auch klar die Kollegin
weiß hat das von uns schon
ausgeführt mit diesem unkonkreten Antrag
mit diesem Dreizeiler der Linken lassen
sich die aktuellen Herausforderungen der
Krise nicht lösen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Lagen
der wir uns befinden ist dramatisch
ich habe Angst
das Schreiben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
uns Abgeordneten in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder und in solchen Momenten
frage ich mich was antworten Sie
eigentlich sie Abgeordnete von der
ampelfraktion den Bürgern you'll never
walk alone also ich hoffe ihnen fällt
noch etwas besseres ein denn warme Worte
heizen keine Wohnung
die Wahrheit ist viele Menschen fühlen
sich von der Bundesregierung alleine
gelassen da sind die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner die bis vor kurzem in den
entlastungspaketen einfach ausgespart
worden ein Viertel unserer Bevölkerung
Menschen die oft über wenig Ersparnisse
verfügen oder sich nicht einfach so mal
eben was dazu verdienen können und
deswegen sagen wir es ist gut dass die
ampelregierung jetzt auf unsere Kritik
hin reagiert und auch Rentnern und
Studierenden eine energiepauschale
gewähren will schlecht dass es so lange
gedauert hat
da sind jene 30 Millionen Menschen die
das Pech haben eine Gasheizung in ihrer
Wohnung zu haben sie hätten mit der
unsozialen gasumlage fast ein
doppelwumms auf Ihre Heizkostenrechnung
bekommen warum weil der ampelregierung
nichts besseres eingefallen ist als die
Rettung der Energieversorgung unseres
Landes einseitig auf die Gaskunden
abzuwälzen gut dass sie Herr Habeck
unserem Appell buchstäblich in letzter
Minute gefolgt sind und ihre unsoziale
gasumlage gestoppt haben schlecht dass
es so lange gedauert hat
da sind die kleinen Betriebe die
Handwerker die nicht wissen wie sie die
Gehälter zahlen sollen weil die
Energiekosten schon jetzt nicht mehr zu
stemmen sind bis heute ist unklar wie
die ampelregierung Arbeitsplätze bei
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen
erhalten möchte gut und das möchte ich
an der Stelle auch sagen dass unser
grüner Wirtschaftsminister wenigstens
eingesehen hat dass man nicht einfach
folgenlos aufhören kann zu produzieren
schlecht das ist so lange gedauert hat
denn die Insolvenzen sind bereit zum ein
Drittel im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
gestiegen
und da sind die Familien mit Kindern
Alleinerziehende Menschen im
Niedriglohnsektor die sich mit den
Energiepreisen alleine gelassen fühlen
da sind die sozialen Einrichtungen die
gemeinnützigen Vereine die Krankenhäuser
die nicht wissen wie sie durch den
Winter kommen deswegen ist es jetzt so
wichtig auch ein sozialen Hilfsfonds
aufzusetzen der explizit auch die
sozialen Dienstleister mit einbezieht
damit nicht jene alleingelassen werden
die gerade in der Krise stark belastet
sind auch das empfiehlt im übrigen die
Expertenkommission
an dieser Stelle ein ganz herzlichen
Dank übrigens an die 20-köpfige
Kommission die innerhalb von 48 Stunden
aufholen musste was die ampelfraktionen
einem halben Jahr hier an Energie
verschwendet haben während sie sich im
oppositionsmodus an 16 Jahren
erfolgreicher unionsgeführter
Regierungsarbeit abkämpften
wir als Union lassen die Menschen nicht
alleine unsere Lösungsvorschläge liegen
seit mehreren Monaten auf dem Tisch nur
um einige zu nennen bürgerbasispreis
einführen 1.000 Euro sofort helfen für
Haushalte im unteren einkommensdrittel
Hilfspakete für kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen und natürlich und vor allem
alle zur Verfügung stehenden
Produktionskapazitäten nutzen auch die
Kernkraft
und wir haben das heute ja auch schon
von meiner Kollegin gehört Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz rühmt sich ja ganz gerne
damit auf Krisen vorbereitet zu sein und
alles schon vorher gewusst zu haben erst
vorgestern sagte er dass sich das
Kanzleramt angeblich seit Dezember
letzten Jahres auf eine mögliche
Energiekrise vorbereitet und trotzdem
stehen wir hier und Mitte Oktober liegen
immer noch keine Vertrauen schaffenden
beschlussfähigen Lösungen vor wir als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion von Sie
deshalb auf endlich aus der Beratung
herauszufinden und Führung in der Krise
zu beweisen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
haben ein Anrecht darauf dass die
Bundesregierung jetzt handelt das
Beschwören von Fußballhymnen reicht
jedenfalls nicht vielen Dank
Ottilie klein war das Abgeordnete der
Unionsfraktion unter anderem Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und
damit kommen wir zur vorletzten Rednerin
in dieser Debatte das ist Hanna
Steinmüller für Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Mieterinnen und Mieter stehen gerade
extrem unter Druck das wissen wir
steigende Energiepreise steigende
Lebensmittelpreise und wenn es schlecht
läuft und man einen indexmietvertrag hat
auch noch stark steigenden Mietkosten
die Bundesregierung und wir als
Parlament versuchen Mieterinnen und
Mieter in dieser schwierigen Zeit zu
unterstützen für uns ist klar niemand
soll in kalten oder im Dunklen in seiner
Wohnung sitzen oder die Wohnung im
schlimmsten Fall verlieren
zu den Strom und Gaspreisen da sind
Minister Habeck und sein Haus und Steffi
Lemken und ihr Haus bereits im Gespräch
und arbeiten an einer Regelung
mindestens genauso richtig wichtig ist
es aber auch
zielgerichte zu unterstützen damit erst
gar keine energierückstände entstehen
auch darüber sollten wir sprechen dafür
haben wir ein breites Maßnahmen für
Mieterinnen und Mieter geschnürt wir
werden eine heizkostenkomponente im
Wohngeld einfügen darum ging es in der
Debatte der davor ab dem ersten 23
werden 2 Millionen Haushalte in
Deutschland wohngeldberechtigt sein
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger nutzen Sie
diese Möglichkeit es gibt Online-Rechner
prüfen Sie ob auch sie Unterstützung
bekommen können und nutzen sie das
für alle Menschen die jetzt schon Welt
Wohngeld bekommen gibt es einen zweiten
einmaligen Heizkostenzuschuss für
Menschen die Wohngeld bekommen die
BAföG-berechtigt sind Ausbildungs- und
berufshilfe für einen einen
Personenhaushalt sind das 415 Euro bei
zwei Personen kommen 540 Euro zusammen
und für jede weitere Person 100 Euro
mehr wir werden ein gaspreisdecke und
ein strompreisdeckel einführen dazu gab
es wirklich umfangreiche Debatten in den
letzten Tagen und die energiepauschale
in Höhe von 300 Euro sind bereits
ausgezahlt worden auch das ist wichtig
klar ist aber auch
es ist kein Signal der Sorglosigkeit wir
tun alles um Härten abzufedern aber es
darf nicht der Eindruck entstehen dass
niemand was tun müsste das Gebot der
Stunde ist das wer kann Energie sparen
sollte
was können Mieterinnen und Mieter jetzt
tun die ihre Energierichtung nicht mehr
zahlen können die Energie die
Verbraucherschutzzentralen bieten vor
Ort Beratung an auch die
Bundesnetzagentur hat Informationen
bereitgestellt nutzen Sie das und treten
Sie im Zweifelsfall mit ihren Versorgern
in Kontakt liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ist ent extrem herausfordernd Zeiten
energie sparen ist das Gebot der Stunde
die Regierung kann ich alles
kompensieren aber besondere Härten
vermeiden das tun wir mit verschiedenen
Maßnahmen vielen Dank
Hanna Steinmüller hat hier noch einmal
die Arbeit der Regierungskoalition
verteidigt und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner das ist Jan Diren für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen in den demokratischen
Fraktionen die Bundesnetzagentur
berichtet dass 20 Jahr seid ihr nicht
einbezogen das im Jahr 2021 knapp
235.000 Haushalten in Deutschland der
Strom abgedreht wurde ein Vergleich in
Städten meines Wahlkreises Moers Krefeld
Neukirchen-Vluyn leben insgesamt weniger
als
200.000 Haushalte das heißt es würde
bedeuten für alle Menschen in meinem
Wahlkreis bliebe morgens das Licht aus
die Wohnung dunkel und kalt noch
häufiger als dass diese Sperren verhängt
werden wenn sie aber angedroht 2021 für
über 4 Millionen Haushalte Deutschland
über vier Millionen dass jeder zehnte
Haushalt in Deutschland es ist
selbstverständlich richtig dafür zu
sorgen dass Menschen in diesem Winter
nicht ohne Strom und Heizung dastehen
gerade jetzt gerade in diesem Winter
deshalb bin ich Ihnen dankbar die
Kollegin von den Linken dass sie die
Problematik mit ihrem Antrag hier auf
die Tagesordnung setzen gleichzeitig ist
die Sache ein bisschen verstrickter als
es auf den ersten Blick scheint denn auf
der anderen Seite der Kundin die ihre
Rechnung nicht bezahlen können stehen
die Unternehmen die ihre Rechnung nicht
bezahlt bekommen
wenn ihr Energiepreise steigen und
Rechnungen nicht bezahlt werden laufen
auch diese Unternehmen eventuell auf
eine Zahlungsunfähigkeit hin uns hier
stellt das von politisches Dilemma weil
das auf die Alternative hinausläuft dass
entweder reihenweise Stadtwerke und
damit die Daseinsvorsorge zusammenbricht
oder so viele Menschen in Deutschland
kalten und Dunkeln sitzen bleiben liebe
Kolleginnen mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse reagieren wir jetzt auf
dieses Dilemma denn mit ihr wollen wir
dafür sorgen dass einerseits die
Menschen in Deutschland ihre Rechnung
bezahlen können und andererseits sperren
in diesem Winter verhindert werden
jetzt äußern manche die Sorge diese
gaspreisbremse könnte unbeabsichtigt die
Folge haben den freien Markt
einzuschränken
die freie Preisbildung am Markt zu
wenden diese Sorge kann ich ihnen nehmen
das wird keine unbeabsichtigte Folge
sein das ist genau das worum es uns
dabei geht es geht genau darum in die
freie Preisbildung am Markt einzugreifen
weil der freie Markt die freie
Preisbildung am Markt uns ja immer und
immer wieder vor dieses Dilemma stellt
entweder steigen die Preise so weit die
Leute ihre Rechnung nicht bezahlen
können oder die Unternehmen
die wir so dringend brauchen um unsere
Grundbedürfnisse zu befriedigen brechen
zusammen auf dem einen oder anderen Weg
kommen wir so zum selben Ergebnis wir
schaffen es nicht unsere
Grundbedürfnisse zu denken
ein Markt aber
mit dem wir nicht dafür sorgen können
dass wir auch nur unsere
Grundbedürfnisse befrieden befriedigen
können das ist ein Markt der nicht
funktioniert und es muss auch nicht so
sein es muss ja nicht so sein dass
Unternehmen mit der Versorgung von
Grundbedürfnissen Strom Heizung Wasser
wohnen Profit machen während die
Menschen ihre Grundbedürfnisse nicht
befriedigen können weil sie ihre
Rechnung nicht mehr zahlen können und es
sollte auch nicht so sein bei dem Großen
und Ganzen mag das ja noch so
einigermaßen aufgehen aber zu welchen
Problemen das immer und immer wieder
führt sehen wir in Krisen wie dieser und
wir sehen das gerade am Beispiel der
Strom und gassperre
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen ist die
gaspreisbremse über die wir gerade
diskutieren so viel mehr als nur ein
Instrument das dafür sorgt dass die
Menschen ihre Rechnung bezahlen können
die Diskussion um die gaspreisbremse
jetzt gerade markiert die Einsicht dass
wir nicht blind dem freien Spiel des
Marktes vertrauen können wenn es darum
geht unsere Grundbedürfnisse zu decken
und sie markiert die Einsicht dass wir
genau dieses System ändern müssen um das
besser hinzukriegen dafür zu sorgen dass
Menschen in warmen Wohnungen sitzen
Strom Gas versorgen haben und ihre
Grundbedürfnisse befriedigen können das
ist die eigentliche Aufgabe von der wir
gerade stehen gehen wir sie an vielen
Dank
die Aussprache und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und
Energie zu dem Antrag der Fraktion Die
Linke mit dem Titel Strom und Gas
sperren verbieten der Ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 38 53 den Antrag der
Fraktion Die Linke auf Drucksache 2686
abzulehnen die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat
hierfür namentliche Abstimmung verlangt
und die erfolgt jetzt gleich in der
westlobby ich bitte allerdings die
Abgeordneten im Saal noch sitzen zu
bleiben da noch weitere Abstimmungen so
über wie Überweisungen und die
abschließenden Beratung ohne Aussprache
folgen und da eben diese Beratung wie
Katrin Göring-Eckardt gerade angekündigt
hat ohne diese Abstimmung ohne Beratung
stattfinden werden wollen wir dann
lieber die Zeit nutzen Sie über andere
wichtige Neuigkeiten zu informieren
natürlich kommen wir aber zum Bundestag
wieder zurück wenn es hier weitergeht
denn da wird es äußerst pikante zugehen
vor zwei Tagen ist nämlich ein Buch
erschienen die Akte Scholz der Kanzler
das Geld und die Macht und der geht es
wieder einmal um den Warburg Steuer
Skandal denn in diesem Buch wird
beschrieben das Kanzler Olaf Scholz
nicht wie bisher bekannt sehr wohl
Erinnerungen hat an die Treffen mit der
Hamburger Warburg Bank und deswegen hat
die Unionsfraktion eine Aktuelle Stunde
beantragt wie gesagt wenn es soweit ist
dann kommen wir hier wieder live in den
Deutschen Bundestag zurück aber jetzt
erst einmal gebe ich ab zum Studio zu
Stefan Kulle
Katharina kühn vielen Dank nach Berlin
machen wir natürlich wir kommen dann
wieder zurück und wollen das pikante
sehr gerne transportieren meine Damen
und Herren das 9 Euro Ticket sie
erinnern sich dann gar nicht so lange
her war doch irgendwie ein Erfolgsmodell
das sind sich alle doch ziemlich einig
außer ein paar Ausreißer jetzt soll es
dafür einen Nachfolger
Nachfolgemodell da haben sich Bund und
Länder schon grundsätzlich für geeinigt
man hat wohl so hört man auch schon
einen Preis gefunden nämlich 49 Euro
unklar ist bislang und das ist der auch
Gegenstand des Streites zwischen Bund
und Ländern wie das Ganze finanziert
werden sollen und sitzen die
Verkehrsminister des Bundes und der
Länder zusammen und haben